which starts tonight at 10:00 Eastern on
c-span 3 Wednesday on the c-span
networks on Washington journal a preview
of House debate on Defense Authorization
with Republican Congressman Curt Weldon
and Democrat Jean Taylor both on the
Armed Services Committee and that debate
begins when the House gavels in 10:00
a.m. Eastern on c-span 2 the Senate
continues work on a bill that would
allow small businesses to group together
and purchase health care and on c-span 3
a House hearing on supply and pricing of
gas later
the CEO of Eli Lilly on health care and
prescription drug prices and a house
panel here is from inspectors general on
combating fraud related to Hurricane
Katrina now a Senate hearing on Brett
Cavanaugh's judicial nomination to the
District of Columbia federal appeals
court after this enrolling in Medicare
prescription drug program before
Monday's deadline judiciary committee
will proceed with the nomination of
Brett Kavanaugh to be a judge for the
Court of Appeals for the District of
Columbia Circuit at the outset we
welcome judge Walter Stapleton Court of
Appeals of the Third Circuit and judge
Alex was in Ski Court of Appeals for the
Ninth Circuit we appreciate your coming
in today mr. Cavanaugh is in an unusual
circumstance of not having senators to
introduce him he's DC Marylander and as
of this moment the senators from his
home state of Maryland are not available
to make the introductions and the
committee has asked Judge Stapleton and
Judge Kozinski to do that since they
have special
knowledge of the nominee because he
clerked for them they have special
insights into his background just a few
words by way of introduction mr.
Cavanaugh will take the witness stand
and will be sworn and will speak for
himself but I think it appropriate to
make a few comments about his record and
about my analysis of these proceedings I
have been surprised to see mr. Cavanaugh
characterized as not up to the job of
Judge for the Court of Appeals for the
District of Columbia a circuit I've
taken a look at his record in some
detail and I had a long session with mr.
Cavanaugh and I've asked him all of the
questions which have been posed on his
nomination the issue of the NSA
surveillance program a program that I
have raised serious questions about
asked him about what if anything he had
to do with it and he will speak for
himself and responding to that asked him
about the issue of the issue of
allegations of mistreatment of people on
interrogation on the overlay of torture
or rendition and again he will have an
opportunity to speak for himself on that
subject at our executive committee
session last week the question was
raised about mr. Abramoff he will have
an opportunity to speak for himself
about that question in in reviewing his
record I know that he was Yale College
for his bachelor's degree whom
latte and he was Yale Law School where
he was on the Yale Law Journal how that
takes some substantial academic
qualification something I know about
because I was there and the only
difference between mr. Cavanaugh is a 10
year on the Yale Law Journal and being a
high academic graduate from Yale Law
School difference from my record is that
when he was there the competition was
tougher he's slightly younger than I am
that as the years have passed the Yale
Law School has been more difficult to
attain academic achievement but that's
something I know of firsthand then his
his record beyond law school was to
clerk for judge Stapleton the clerk for
judge Kozinski and they will speak for
themselves
and then he was in the office of
Solicitor General where he argued one
case before the Supreme Court of the
United States and if he were on the
Judiciary Committee would put him in
second place not too bad a place to be
on the Judiciary Committee on Supreme
Court arguments then he's had a number
of arguments and the Court of Appeals
and a number of arguments before
district court on on legal issues then
he served in the office of the
Independent Counsel and that was a
highly controversial office beyond any
question and mr. Kavanagh will describe
his activities there but he was not
counsel he was not deputy counsel he was
one of the tier below where there were
ten associate or assisted counsels there
and I know he'll be asked about what his
participation was there we will hear we
will hear from mr. Kavanagh himself on
that and he has written two
distinguished
illegal pieces published in the journals
one on the independent council and
suggesting changes a hardly the mark of
an ideologue who works as independent
council that has tunnel vision as to
what they did but has expressed a ways
to improve the operation of independent
council showing an open mind and showing
us some progressive thinking as to
utilizing his experience and then he
wrote an article on the issue of
peremptory challenges for
african-americans and has a very
difficult to use the words liberal or
conservative over progressive his own
hide around here but he's on the right
side of that issue an issue that I
understand well when I became District
Attorney of Philadelphia I didn't need
to have the federal courts tell me not
to have peremptory challenge for black
science instruction to my assistants
that they couldn't ask for it
and finally the courts caught up with it
mr. Kavanagh will speak as to his views
on that subject but hardly the views of
a cramped conservative but he will he
will describe his views on all of on all
of these matters and then he went to
Kirkland and Ellis which is a very
distinguished law firm I don't know how
many people from the Judiciary Committee
could be employed by Kirkland and Ellis
today let alone out of law school tough
road to hoe and he was taken in as a
partner not an equity partner that's all
complicated now with law firms a non
equity partner but that's an unusual
call for a firm like Kirkland and
Alistair for any big firm of their
nature because of the how they evaluated
this background and and its experience
now he's been associate counsel to the
President and now he's a staff secretary
to the President and if he
reflects the views consistent with the
president that's entirely consistent
with having the president nominate
judges that's our system that's decided
by an election but he'll speak for
himself as to where he stands in the
spectrum as to as to being as to being
in the mainstream just a word about the
American Bar Association rating early he
was rated well qualified in the majority
and qualified with the minority count
and then they revile you ated them two
years later and they took some
additional interviews and not
surprisingly the interviews a varied and
now he's been rated than the majority
qualified and the minority
well-qualified so you have him moving
from well-qualified to qualified
qualified to well-qualified and not a
tinkers bit of difference really in
terms of our evaluation because had
minimal he's qualified and they're great
many people think he's unqualified
Senator Schumer Thank You mr. chairman
first let me thank you for holding this
hearing which many of us had requested
and we very much appreciate it and
second I want to thank mr. Cavanaugh for
being back here when we had our private
meeting I asked him if he had any
objections to come back what you
good-naturedly referred to as the arena
and last at our last hearing and you
said no and very much appreciate that
and I realized while this is not always
the most pleasant exercise for a nominee
I think we can all agree it's a very
important one because we're talking
about nothing less momentous than a
lifetime appointment to what is
generally regarded as the second most
important court in the land a court of
great importance to those of us who sit
in the Senate or the house because it
has such jurisdiction over governmental
issues and years after this nomination
there this Court is going to influence a
great deal
what this Congress and future congresses
have done now mr. chairman you know how
many of us have deep concerns about this
nominee just yesterday they were given
further voice in the form of the
American Bar Association's follow-up
report which was made public yesterday
which explained why six members of the
ABA committee felt compelled to
downgrade their rating my concerns are
twofold first although mr. Kavanagh has
held several important and influential
positions in government they have been
almost exclusively political there's no
doubt that mr. Kavanagh you are a highly
successful young attorney and your
academic credentials is certainly
outlined by the Chairman or top notch
but your experience has been most
notable not so much for your blue chip
credentials but for the undeniably
political nature of so many of your
assignments for much of your career your
considerable talents have been enlisted
in partisan and polarizing issues in
short you've been the go-to guy among
young Republican lawyers appearing at
the epicenter of so many high-profile
controversial issues in your short
career and it's only natural that such a
record would give many senators pause
particularly those of us on this side of
the aisle from the notorious Starr
report to the Florida recount to the
president's secrecy and privileged
claims to post 9/11 legislative battles
including the Victims Compensation Fund
to ideological judicial nomination
fights if there's been a partisan
political fight that needed a very
bright legal foot soldier in the last
decade Brett Kavanaugh was probably
there that is that kind of record is not
dispositive to be sure but it feeds an
impression of partisanship that is to
put it mildly not ideal for a nominee
a critically important lifetime post as
a neutral judge now for those who
question the good faith of these
concerns who suggests that some of us
are reflexively or unalterably opposed
to any Republican involved in the
impeachment of President Clinton or
other political causes let me mention
two names Tom Griffith and Paul McNulty
mr. Griffith whom I voted to confirm to
a seat on the very court to which mr.
Cavanaugh expires was Senate legal
counsel during impeachment and Paul
McNulty who I voted to confirm many of
us I think all of us voted to confirm to
be the number two official at the
Department of Justice was chief counsel
and spokesman for the House Judiciary
Committee Republicans during impeachment
despite their blue chip Republican
credentials and participation in
hot-button political issues I was
convinced that both of these men had
expand had it's substantial experience
in professional and non partisan work so
that any concerns about inexperience
cronyism and partisanship was for me at
least and I think for most of us on this
side of the aisle laid to rest so mr.
chairman were all operating in good
faith here and we've demonstrated
ourselves to be open-minded on the
president's nominees to top judicial and
executive posts at last count we've
confirmed 240 of President Bush's
nominees and Democrats have voted for
the vast majority of them then there is
a second and related concern although
mr. Kavanagh is extremely well
credentialed he is younger than and has
had less relevant experience than almost
everyone who has joined the DC Circuit
in modern times
we'd have fewer concerns if the
President had nominated a mainstream
conservative with a record of
independence from partisan politics who
has demonstrated a history of non
partisan service with a proven record of
commitment to the rule of law and who we
could reasonably trust will serve
justice not political patrons or
ideology have confirmed to this powerful
lifetime post both Stephen Breyer and
Ruth Cade
Ginsberg whose biographies are often
cited at these proceedings had
substantial non-political experience
before they were nominated to appellate
courts mr. Cavanaugh if confirmed I
believe would be the youngest person on
the DC Court of DC Circuit since his
mentor Ken Starr and if you go through
the pre confirmation accomplishments of
the active judges who currently sit on
the DC Circuit mr. Cavanaugh has
achievements though impressive are not
on the same scale judge Sentell for
example had extensive practice as a
prosecutor and trial lawyer and
experience as a state judge in as a
federal district court judge judge
Randolph spent 22 years with federal and
state attorneys generals offices
including services Deputy Solicitor
General of the United States and a law
firm partnership judge Rodgers had 30
years of service in both federal and
state governments including a stint as
the corporation counsel for the District
of Columbia and several years on DC's
equivalent of a state Supreme Court like
mr. Cavanaugh many of the nine active
judges on this Court held prestigious
clerkships including clerkships on the
Supreme Court and involvement at the
high levels of government that no doubt
involved some partisan work but they all
had significant additional experience
nonpartisan experience to help persuade
this committee that they merited
confirmation now of course these
concerns are echoed in a new report from
the American Bar Association they cannot
be dismissed as some of my colleagues
suggests as merely intemperate rants by
Democrats on the committee and
predictably of course some are already
launching a campaign to denigrate the
ABA despite boasting of mr. Kavanagh his
original rating two years ago and
attacked the character of one of the ABA
committee members and I hope we would
refrain from doing that according to the
ABA report released yesterday one judge
who saw your our oral presentation in
court mr. Kavanagh
quote you were less than adequate
unquote that you had been sanctimonious
and that you would demonstrated
experience on the level of an associate
a lawyer in a different proceeding had
this to say mr. Cavanaugh did not handle
the case well as an advocate and
dissembled that's a pretty serious
statement according to the report other
lawyers and note the plural expressed
similar concerns repeating and substance
that the nominee was young and
inexperienced in the practice of law
still others again note the plural
characterized mr. Kavanaugh as quote
insulated and in one particular
questioned mr. Kavanaugh is ability
quote to be balanced and fair should he
assume a federal judgeship unquote and
yet another individual said this he said
that mr. Kavanaugh is immovable quote
immovable and very stubborn and
frustrating to deal with on sun ish some
issues these new concerns apparently
based on some 36 additional interviews
were so serious that six members of the
ABA committee changed their vote on the
phone call yesterday I asked mr. Tobler
the head of the committee was it rare
for people to change their vote and he
said no and I said was it usual and he
said no so it happens but it doesn't
happen all that often
we have other reasons for concern I must
say that I was disturbed by some of the
answers I got from you mr. Kavon or the
first time around on the issue of the
role of ideology and judicial philosophy
in the picking of judges by this
administration for example you
repeatedly insisted totally implausibly
that such considerations played no role
that was simply not believable and
frankly put your credibility at issue
you began to clarify your statements in
our meeting last week and I hope we can
have further dialogue but to say that an
ideology had no effect well show me some
nominees to high offices high judicial
offices who were
Macross who were moderates who were
maybe pro-choice trough frozen or Sumer
your past ten minutes how much have I
just have another minute and a half mr.
chairman thank you it was not believable
that's the bottom line
and in addition senators will want to
ask you among other things about your
role and setting of policy relating to
executive power and the separation of
powers you admitted to me for example
that in your job as staff secretary you
had input on the controversial issue of
presidential signing statements there'll
be questions about that I expect you
will also get questions about your
involvement if any in this
administration's detention policies
torture policies and rendition policies
these issues among many others deserve
further scrutiny and given the scant
record we have I hope no one will
question the good faith we have in
asking them so mr. Chairman I would say
that many of my colleagues and I have a
sincere and good-faith concern about
this nominee we feel that the nominee is
not a political enough not seasoned
enough not independent enough and hasn't
been forthcoming enough maybe this
hearing will remove those concerns but
it is certainly necessary last week mr.
Cavanaugh I asked you to think of ways
to alleviate these concerns and I look
forward to hearing your testimony Thank
You mr. chairman thank you Senator
Schumer and I just wanted to the
Chairman lay ranking member Leahy
couldn't be here at the beginning of
this hearing but will be here in about
an hour
Thank You Senator Schumer oh well one
addendum to my comments mr. Kavanagh
also clerked for Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy judge Stapleton and
Judge Kozinski it is our practice to ask
our witnesses to be sworn that
nomination proceedings as we had a
number of Circuit Judges sworn during
the confirmation of Justice Alito so
with your consent would you rise and
take the oath
do you solemnly swear that the testimony
you will give before could you this your
committee will be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you God I do let the record show both
witnesses answered in the affirmative
judge Stapleton you were the First
Circuit Judge for whom mr. Cavanaugh
clerks so we will begin with you mr.
chairman and members of the committee I
appreciate the invitation to introduce
Brett Kavanaugh that's not because I
think he needs any introduction to this
committee but rather because I believe
I'm in a position to share information
that is quite probative with respect to
the important issue that is before you I
have been a federal judge for over 35
years the last 20 of those years as a
member of the Court of Appeals for the
Third Circuit and based on that
experience I believe I understand well
what it takes to be able to serve well
as a United States Circuit Judge I have
known mr. Cavanaugh for well for over 15
years I first met him in March of 1989
when I interviewed him for a clerkship
he had one of the most impressive
resumes I have ever seen and believe me
I have seen a lot of a lot of resumes
among other things as you've noted mr.
chairman he was editor of the Yale Law
Journal and at the point in time I met
him he had received an honours grade in
every course he had taken at Yale Law
School save one best of all the
professors who knew him well assured me
that and I quote his work is uniformly a
very high quality thoughtful independent
minded yet very balanced and always
clearly written unquote I have recently
resurrected the notes I made after our
lengthy personal interview and they say
quote extremely talented mature
confident yet modest good sense of humor
unquote now in other words a judge's
dream of a law of a law clerk and I
didn't have to ponder the decision about
hiring him for very long and he
certainly did not disappoint
and I will always treasure the time that
we shared we worked very hard and we
were asked to resolve many intractable
controversies facing challenges like
that together promotes a bonding process
in which the participants get to know
each other
awfully well and we talked at length not
only about the law and about the
challenges we faced but about his hopes
and aspirations for the future and
towards the end of the clerkship our CH
team to consider the judiciary as a
career if he should ever have that
opportunity and I did that because I
believed he had the makings of my kind
of judge there was no trace of arrogance
and no agenda he applied his legal
acuity and common sense judgment with
equal diligence to every case large or
small undertaking his evaluation of each
without predilection his ultimate
recommendations were based on careful
case-by-case analysis of the facts of
each case and objective application of
the relevant precedents it was clear to
me that he understood the crucial role
of precedent in a society that's
committed to the rule of law brett
thanked me for my advice
but in characteristically modest fashion
said he doubted that he would get the
opportunity to so serve now mr. Kavanagh
of course has had a variety of
opportunities since that time as I knew
he he what anyone with his talents would
have many opportunity
as a result in addition to his
impressive legal skills and I believe
mr. Kavanagh has the the sophistication
the insight and maturity that comes from
having served in a variety of
professional positions noteworthy worthy
not only because of their variety but
also because of the awesome
responsibilities that each carried while
I believe all of his professional
experience would serve him well as a
judge a substantial portion of that
experience renders mr. Kavanagh I
believe exceptionally well qualified in
terms of experience I refer of course to
the fact that in addition to his
exposure to private practice and his
service to the president mr. Kavanagh
has had substantial litigation
experience on both sides of the bench as
you're aware and as the chairman has
mentioned he's worked on with a
one-and-one relationship not only with
the two Court of Appeals judges that are
here this afternoon but also with a
Justice of the United States Supreme
Court and the Solicitor General of the
United States and as you are also aware
mr. Kavanagh is litigation experience
has included appearances before all
levels of our federal courts now I have
stayed in touch with mr. Kavanagh and
have followed his career with interest
since he left my chambers I have heard
nothing from and I've heard nothing
about mr. Kavanagh in the intervening
years that has caused me to question in
any way my original judgment about the
kind of judge he would be if he could
have that opportunity his
responsibilities it's true from time to
time have called upon him to make to
take positions on issues which
reasonable Minds could differ about
that's part of being a lawyer but I
believe he has consistently served his
client well and in a thoroughly
professional manner in some members of
the committee I believe mr. Cavanaugh's
intelligence his common-sense judgment
his temperament and his dedication to
the rule of law make him a superb
candidate for the position of United
States Circuit Judge and I can commend
him to you without reservation thank you
for this opportunity to address the
committee thank you very much sir judge
Stapleton Judge Kozinski my on good
afternoon Monsieur Armand members of the
committee it's great pleasure and honor
for me to be back thank you for inviting
me to introduce my good friend my former
law clerk Brett Kavanaugh I probably
don't need to take my full five minutes
because I can just say me to to
everything that just stapled and said
but let me just take a few minutes I was
a couple of minutes if I can to to give
my own personal view I'm glad the
chairman that you mentioned that Brett
Kavanaugh went to Yale and you and he
had that in common we have that in
common too
he went to Yale and I have a son named
to Yale I try to get him but I wasn't as
fortunate I got rejected but I have had
a number of clerks from Yale and and
Harvard and many other fine law schools
and they among them Brett Kavanaugh was
one of the finest I met him about the
same time they just stabled met him in
March 89 we both interviewed him for a
job for clerkship right out of Law
School
but just Abelson was just faster making
an offer so I had to pick him up the
following year because he accepted it
was just a token first in the time that
I had clerk and Brett clerked for me I
found him to be a positive delight to
have in the office sure I mean he is
really bright and he's really
accomplished and he's a really excellent
lawyer but
most virtually all folks who qualify for
a clerkship with a circuit judge these
days have those qualities but Brad
brought something more to the table he
first of all brought what I thought was
a breadth of mind and a blitz of vision
he didn't look at the case when just one
perspective like a good lawyer like Jim
and you were a prosecutor you know this
very well you have to look at a case
from different perspectives not just one
and not early in the case take one
perspective and then stick with it but
it was very good
in changing perspectives sometimes I
take one position and he take the
opposite and sometimes with switch
places he was very good and very
flexible that way I never sensed any
ideology or any agenda his job was to
serve me and to serve the court and
serve the people of the United States in
in achieving the correct result the
court and he always did it with a sense
of humor and a sense of self gentle self
deprecation he was always my staff my
secretaries his co clerks all enjoyed
having him and all enjoyed particularly
the fact that he was not in any way
pompous or in any way stuck on himself
but was always ready to help others
always ready to be friendly with others
and I think that's a very important
quality in a job this may seem trivial
and maybe seem like I'm mentioning
things here that ought to be mentioned
in the committee but part of what makes
the job of judging different from a lot
of other judges is it is not a jobs it
is not a mechanical process it is
ultimately a human process you have to
understand something about how people
think something about how people live
something about how people feel and what
I think Brett Kavanaugh brings to the
table but he brought to the table when
he was my law clerk is a sense of
humanity and a sense of understanding I
will not speak to the question of
confirmation long confirmation this
obviously is something that the
committee is up to the committee I can
only say that I give Brett Kavanaugh my
highest recommendation I gave them my
highly commendation when he applied to
Justice Kennedy my own mentor and I
continue to give him the highest
recommendations Thank You mr. chairman
thank you thank you very much I have
just one question for each of you
Jessica Sinskey how old were you when
you were appointed to the Ninth Circuit
I was 35 years old mr. chairman
and Judge Stapleton how old were you
when you were appointed to the federal
bench first to the district court 35
years old and made the record show that
Justice Kennedy was appointed to the
Ninth Circuit when he was 38 years old
anybody have any questions for the
judges
Senator Schumer one question for both
since mr. Cavanaugh clerked for you each
of you right after a year after law
school have either of you had occasion
to have him appear before you in your
court as a lawyer I have not nor have I
thanks thank you very much judge
Stapleton thank you very much judge
Kozinski appreciate your being here my
pleasure thanks Cavanaugh would you step
forward for the right hand do you swear
that the testimony you will give before
the judiciary committee will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you God I do now
before beginning your testimony mr.
Cavanaugh I note an infant in the
audience and what appears to be a mother
and both appear to be wife and child and
perhaps other family would you introduce
them please yes thank you very much mr.
chairman for the opportunity to appear
here before the committee I'm grateful
to the president for nominating me
this important traveling oh there's a
question pending and the question was
would you introduce your family yes and
I thank my family for being here since I
last appeared before the committee have
been to major changes in my record and
they're both sitting behind me my wife
Ashley Estes Cavanaugh and my eight
month old daughter Margaret Murphy
Cavanaugh she she's watched a little
c-span in her day this is her first live
Senate hearing however I'm not sure as
you've probably already noticed mr.
chairman I'm not sure she's gonna make
it very long but she wanted to be here
for the start
my uncle Marc Murphy is here and my
brother-in-law JD Estes is here my mom
and dad are here Martha and Ed Cavanaugh
they are and have been an inspiration to
me they've been married for 43 years and
I am their only child they I'm just very
proud that they're behind me today my
mom in particular in terms of career
path has had a profound influence on my
career choices throughout her life she's
been dedicated to public service when
she was in her 20s she taught public
high school in the District of Columbia
and McKinley and HD Woodson high schools
she then decided to go back to law
school in the 1970s and became a state
prosecutor out in Rockville Maryland she
was later appointed to the State trial
bench by Governor Shafer and then by
governor Glendenning in Maryland
she's instilled in me a commitment to
public service and a respect for the
rule of law that I've tried to follow
throughout my career mr. chairman I'm a
product of my parents I'm also a product
of my experiences and I'd like to take a
few minutes to share a few those
experiences and how they I think they
might shape how I would come to the
bench as a judge I attended Yale Law
School in the late 1980s it was a
challenging yet collegial environment it
was a place that instilled a desire to
make a difference
it was a place that encouraged public
service and while I was at Yale Law
School I decided as you know to seek a
judicial clerkship after my time there I
clerked for judge Walter Stapleton on
the Third Circuit Judge Stapleton is a
gentleman and a scholar he's an
experienced judge and he's a great
friend if I'm confirmed to be a judge
I'll do everything in my power to bring
to the bench the decency and the good
judgment and the collegial manner of
Walter Stapleton and I thank him for
being here today
after I clerked for judge Stapleton I
clerked for Judge Alex Kaczynski on the
9th Circuit Judge Kozinski as many of
you know has a passion for the law we
started as law clerks he told us we work
for the people we should consider
ourselves on the job 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year
and I can say from personal experience
the judge Kozinski lived up to that
promise we worked very hard he was very
thorough I thank him for all he's done
for me in my career and for coming here
today from California if I am confirmed
to be a judge I would seek to bring to
the bench the thoroughness and the
thoughtfulness and the dedication of the
rule of law that Judge Kozinski has
demonstrated on the bench for more than
two decades after I finished those two
clerkships I worked in the Solicitor
General's Office at the Department of
Justice I experienced the ethic of that
office that the United States wins its
point when justice is done in that
office I had the opportunity for the
first time to argue a case in court
before the Fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals I was able to stand up for the
first time and say Brett Kavanaugh for
the United States a moment that was very
proud for me and it remained so and now
October 1993 term of the Supreme cleric
Court I clerked for Justice Anthony
Kennedy Justice Kennedy is a student of
history he's a student of the Supreme
Court he talks often about the compact
between generations that the
Constitution represents and he conveyed
to his clerks and certainly conveyed to
me to use one of his
phrases the essential neutrality of the
law I'm forever grateful to Justice
Kennedy for the opportunity to clerk for
him after I finished that clerkship I
worked for Judge Starr in the
independent counsel's office it was a
difficult it was a tough job it was an
often thankless job in that capacity I
had the opportunity to argue cases
before the Supreme Court of the United
States and the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals I learned some lessons in that
office I had some thoughts about how it
all operated and as the chairman has
noted I tried to make a contribution the
improvement of the public legal system
by writing an article in the Georgetown
Law Journal that identified better ways
in my judgment to conduct investigations
of high-level executive branch officials
I then went to Kirkland and Ellis where
I became a partner represented
institutional clients of the firm and
also did pro bono work for several years
in 2001 I joined the White House
counsel's office under Judge al Gonzales
in that office I did some of the
standard work of the office ethics
issues separation of powers issues I
also worked with many members of the
staff of this committee and other
members of Congress on civil justice
issues such as class-action reform
medical liability reform and the very
important terrorism insurance
legislation in 2002 I also worked on
judges on the nomination of judges and
had the opportunity to help recommend
judges to the President of the United
States for him to nominate to the
federal courts in that capacity on the
district court level I worked closely
with many members of the Senate and
their staffs and the states that I was
assigned including some members of this
committee in July of 2003 I became staff
secretary to President Bush this is what
I call an honest broker for the
president someone who tries to ensure
that the range of policy views on
various subjects in the administration
are presented to the president in a fair
and even-handed way I worked closely
with the president with the senior staff
at the White House and other members of
the administration for nearly three
years I think I've earned the trust of
the president I've earned the trust of
the scene
your staff that I'm fair and even-handed
this kind of high-level experience in
the executive branch has been common for
past judicial nominees especially on the
DC Circuit which handles so many
important and complicated administrative
and constitutional issues mr. Chairman I
have dedicated my career to public
service I revere the rule of law I know
firsthand the central role of the courts
in protecting the rights and liberties
of the people and I pledge to each
member of this committee and I pledge to
each member of the Senate that if
confirmed I will interpret the law as
written and not impose personal policy
preferences that I'll exercise judicial
power prudently
and with restraint that I'll follow
precedent in all cases fully and fairly
and above all that I will in at all
times maintain the absolute independence
of the judiciary which in my judgment is
the crown jewel of our constitutional
democracy mr. chairman would be happy to
answer any questions thank you thank you
very much mr. Kavanagh we now turn to
five-minute round for each senator miss
Kavanagh I begin with the question as to
what assurances can you give this
committee in the Senate and the American
people about your independence from the
President on the White House I look at a
long list of nominees who have voted
against their presidential nominee or
many many celebrated matters just a few
Justice Douglas dissented on the
Korematsu case the Japanese internment
case against President Roosevelt's
policy famous decision by Justice Tom
Clark turning against Truman on the
steel seizure case not long after he was
nominated Justice Kennedy justice
O'Connor disagreeing on
a woman's right to choose from President
Reagan justice Souter disagreeing with
President Bush the elder famous
disagreements that President Eisenhower
expressed about Chief Justice Warren
perhaps the most famous case Salomon
Chase had advocated policies as a
secretary of the Treasury and then after
being appointed to the Supreme Court
declared the unconstitutional the
monetary policy he had implemented as
President Lincoln's treasurer what
positive assurances can you give of your
independence mr. chairman if confirmed
to be a DC Circuit Judge I will call
them as I see him regardless of who the
litigants may be I know that
independence of the judiciary as I said
in my opening is a key part of our
constitutional system I would not
hesitate in any case to rule the way I
saw the case regardless of who the
parties were regardless of whether the
president was involved would you
consider it would you consider yourself
independent of the tradition of the
judges justices whom I've just named
absolutely mr. Chairman I know that
there's a long history in our
constitutional system of judges being
drawn from the executive branch and I
was let me interrupt you there's a great
deal to cover and I only have five
minutes do you have anything to do with
the issues of interrogation of prisoners
relating to the allegations of torture
and the so called Bibby memorandum no
mr. chairman do you have anything to do
with the questions of rendition no mr.
chairman you have anything to do with
the questions relating to detention of
inmates at Guantanamo no mr. chairman
did you have anything to do with mr.
Abramoff and the many visits which he
apparently made to the White House no
mr. chairman do you have anything to do
with the president's policy on so-called
signing statements mr. chairman signing
statements come through the staff
secretary's office and I help ensure
that relevant members of the
administration have provided input on
signing statements in the first instance
they're drafted in the Justice
Department but I do help clear those
before the president sees them that
poses a very difficult and contentious
issue was just committees going to have
hearings on and I can understand that in
your role as coordinator you would have
the responsibility for coalescing
materials did you take any position as
to the constitutional authority for the
president's a limit the substance of
legislation by expressing limitations in
the signing statements mr. chairman it
is common for signing statements this
president in previous presidents to
identify potential constitutional issues
like appointments clause issues
presentment Clause issues or issues
relating to I&S versus charter for
example the line-item veto case on those
matters I make sure that they are that
they would properly staffed other
members of the White House staff they
come up in the first instance from the
Justice Department the office of
management were you called upon to give
the president any advice as to the
constitutional implications of their
signing statements well mr. chairman I
think without discussing internal
matters I think it's common to explain
the general parameters of signing
statements for example that there's been
a history of them and identifying
potential constitutional issues in
legislation particularly appointments
clause presentment clause and the other
issues identified mr. Kavanagh you have
he wrote an article on peremptory
challenges where there had been a
practice among prosecutors to issue what
are called peremptory challenges which
for those who don't know means that a
prospective juror can be disqualified
without stating any reason where blacks
were eliminated my time is about is
about but I will quit but you can answer
mr. chairman I think one of the great
Supreme Court decisions ever decided was
Batson versus Kentucky it overruled
Swain versus Alabama and held that a
prong
kut'rs use of race and striking
potential juries jurors from the jury
box was unconstitutional under the Equal
Protection Clause the 14th amendment one
of the concerns I had that was decided
in 1986 I was in law school from 1987 to
1990 one of the concerns I had was what
procedures will be used to help
guarantee that right to be free of
racial discrimination in the jury
selection procedure and I wrote a note
that advocated certain procedures that
help ferret out potential race racial
bias in the jury selection process
Senator Schumer Thank You mr. chairman
just when Senator Specter went over all
of the issues he mentioned torture in
connection with the Bybee memo were you
involved in any way in the counsel's
office in opining about the proper use
of torture no senator the first time I
learned of that memo I believed and
asked about the memo I asked just in
general no senator thank you okay
I'd like to ask you a few questions that
you did not answer these were submitted
in writing or orally at the last hearing
I think I'll tell you all of them first
Senator Leahy asked you whether Karl
Rove was involved in the judicial
selection process at any point while you
were there I asked you how you would
have voted on the impeachment to
President Clinton senator Kennedy asked
you whether you agreed with Judge Pryor
who called roe v wade an abomination and
Senator Durbin asked you if you consider
yourself in the mold of Scalia and
Thomas which is the mold that the
president has said he was going to
choose judges in first Rove was Karl
Rove involved in any of the selection of
judges while you were there mr. chairman
I think that's a question that the
council to the president should answer
in the first instance I don't think as a
judicial nominee here I should talk
about who's involved counsel to the
president chairs the judicial selection
committee and if there is a question
about who's involved in recommending
judge we're trying to determine in your
previous
previous time you were here you said
that no ideology was involved in the
selection of judges I don't see why you
can't answer that question what's
improper about answering that question
senator I'll check whether I can answer
that question if I can I will provide
the what would come to mind which would
prevent you from answering that question
I just want to be careful that I check
with the council on something like that
and be sure that there's not an issue
before I disclose something in the condo
or any privilege that would prevent you
that you can see that can come to mind
right now I can check with the Council
on that Saturday and do you have
knowledge of the answer well I was
involved in the judicial selection so
you would know yes or no you just choose
not to answer and I'd be happy to
provide the answer I just want to check
with Council next how would you have
voted I know you were involved in the
impeachment of President Clinton how
would you have voted if you were a
senator saying I don't think it's
appropriate for the office that
submitted the report to comment on
whether the house made the proper
decision to impeach or whether the
Senate made the proper decision not when
lawyers argue cases all the time they
say they're disappointed in the verdict
they're happy with the verdict that's
not a violation of anything as far as I
know except your desire not to answer
the question I guess this gets to an
ethic I've learned about prosecutors
offices when I worked in the Solicitor
General's Office and it's not
appropriate to comment on a jury verdict
and I don't think it's appropriate in
this instance for me as a member of the
independent counsel's office to comment
on whether the house decision was
correct or whether the Senate decision
was correct you in an op-ed in the
Washington Post in 1999 you wrote a
defense of Ken Starr where you said
Starr uncovered a massive effort by the
President to lie under oath and obstruct
justice you also wrote that quote the
word that ordinarily describes such
behavior is not trapped but guilty but
now you were pretty clear to state your
views in 1999 but you don't want to
state them now I think that was based on
Judge rights finding of contempt and
there was also a censure resolution
introduced in the Senate that used some
more language so I think the language
there it was a joint talk
just said you didn't think it was
appropriate to answer and you felt it
very appropriate in a similar role to
answer to to make some very strong
statements then I think this goes to a
key point senator which is impeachment
and and then conviction taken to account
more than just the facts as you know
from participating on the house side at
the time and the Senators know from
participating on the Senate side there I
participated in both let him finish his
answer and both sides
that's right and I think as many of the
Senators and House members discussed at
the time it wasn't just a simple
question of whether there was a
violation of law committed but there
were broader considerations for the
country and that's where it really gets
really gets I think improper for someone
in the independent counsel's office to
say whether they think the president
should have been in PA I fail to see the
distinction let me ask you to answer
since my time is ending here the two
other questions do you consider roe v
wade to be an abomination and do you
consider yourself to be a judicial
nominee like the president said he was
going to nominate people in the mold of
Scalia and Thomas senator on the
question of roe v wade if confirmed to
the DC Circuit I would follow roe v wade
faithfully and fully that would be
binding precedent in the court it's been
decided by the Supreme Court in your own
opinion you know and I'm saying if I
were confirmed to the DC Circuit senator
I would follow it it's been reaffirmed
many times including in Planned
Parenthood very understand but what is
your opinion you're not on the bench yet
you've talked about these issues in the
past to other people I'm sure this the
Supreme Court has held repeatedly
senator and I don't think it would be
appropriate for me to give up not
answering questions how about being in
the mold of Scalia and Thomas I don't
want to talk about current members the
court I do think I can describe some of
the justices or judges in the past that
I think I would try that have been role
models to me including justice white
justice Jackson and for a couple reasons
they were people who took an active part
in our government system which is
something I understand just explained to
me why it's appropriate for the
president to say
he will appoint nominees in a particular
mold but you can't answer whether you
would be part of that as a potential
inferior court judge senator on the DC
Circuit if confirmed I just don't want
to talk about currently sitting members
of the Supreme Court I'm happy to talk
about justice Jackson and justice white
she's like okay I wish I could say it
but I don't think you've clarified any
of these answers that we asked you the
first time Thank You mr. chairman
senator hatch well thank you mr.
chairman welcome again to the committee
if you're one of the views had this
great experience of being brought back
here twice and let me just take it mr.
chairman I'd like to take most of my
time to make just a few comments rather
than to ask questions at this time I
think that during his first hearing - in
2004 and is written submissions
afterwards mr. Kavanagh more than
adequately answered all the questions
that have been posed to him the
committee already has a 159 page hearing
record before it on this nominee and I'm
confident and mr. Cavanaugh's abilities
and and capacities both the
understanding and knowledge of the law I
suspect that that he will continue to
show of his intellect sound judgment and
judicial temperament I have no doubt
that mr. Cavanaugh fully appreciates the
proper role and limitations placed on
federal appellate judges in our
constitutional system and while I'm not
pleased with all the circumstances that
have resulted in holding this unusual if
not unprecedented precedent and second
hearing I take solace in the fact that
Chief Justice Roberts and many in the
public and a super majority of senators
found to be an extremely capable
individual after his confirmation
hearings last September was also subject
to two confirmation hearings before he
was able to sit on the DC Circuit I hope
that Brett Cavanaugh's confirmation will
not be delayed as long as the now Chief
Justice Roberts was he was delayed for
11 solid years between the time that the
first President Bush nominated him and
the time that the second President Bush
our current president Rhee nominated him
now while today's hearing will and
should concentrate and focus on quality
patience of Brett Kavanaugh at a circum
the serve on the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals when you see nominees with the
backgrounds of John Robert Roberts and
Brett Kavanaugh having been held up for
so many years for so little reason
sometimes you have to ask yourself if
there may be motivations that played
that if nothing at all to do with the
nominees actual fitness to sit on the
bench to date it's been almost three
years since mr. Kavanaugh was first
nominated I think it's time to vote on
his nomination and frankly it's past
time for the Senate to vote on mr.
Kavanagh s nomination so at this point
I'd like to welcome you mr. Cavanaugh
your your wife and baby and of course
your family since the last time before
this committee yet you've become a
husband and father and I join in
welcoming mrs. Cavanaugh here and your
eight month old daughter Margaret to the
committee I also want to acknowledge the
presence of mr. Cavanaugh his parents
I've known them for a long time
Edie Cavanaugh for many years he headed
up the major trade association the
cosmetic toiletry and fragrance
Association and he is deservedly admired
by many in this town and his mother
served with distinction as a state court
judge in Maryland for many many years
now sometimes in these confirmation
hearings in the rush to get more to more
controversial matters there's a tendency
to skip over too quickly on the
qualities and attributes that led the
president to nominate the individual and
in this case mr. Cavanaugh in the first
place and ethics in respect or has
already given us an overview of the
nominees impressive educational and
employment background we've also heard
the testimony of two excellent federal
court judges for whom Clerk both of whom
I know judge Kozinski of the Ninth
Circuit of course judge Stapleton of the
Third Circuit Court of Appeals I think
we should weigh their words very
carefully these are people with
impeccable reputation and ability on the
bench not only did you distinguish
yourself as a clerk on two appellate
courts but you also served on the as a
clerk on the Supreme Court yet an
academic career that was pretty
impressive as well at Yale
you've had a series of impressive and
highly responsible jobs and in
both the executive branch and in the
private sector and you're in a talented
appellate advocate as well before the
Supreme Court now let me just say my
time is running out but in addition to
your three judicial clerkships as you've
mentioned you've worked in the Solicitor
General's Office in the Department of
Justice with Ken Starr and of course
with the Office of Special Counsel and
of course nobody should judge you as an
attorney for having worked in something
that wasn't unpleasant as that attorneys
work on unpleasant matters in in many
ways and you'd be pretty doggone poor
attorney if you weren't willing to to to
work with distinction and with the
fairness when called upon to do so and I
think knowing you and knowing what
happened in the Clinton matter you serve
with distinction and fairness my time is
about up so I just I'll make some more
comments if we have another round but I
just want to congratulate you for
standing in there and being willing to
serve on the certain Court of Appeals I
know you can make a fortune on the
outside but you've made public service
your life and I don't see how we can
find a better person to serve and give
public service than you so I just want
to personally express my fondness for
you my high admiration for you and the
fact that that you'll have my support in
every step every step of this this
process Thank You senator hatch under
the early broke rule all the side for
the Democrats or senator Feinstein
Senator Durbin senator Kennedy and
Senator Feingold all the Republican side
or senator Coburn's and their Graham
senator sessions and Senator Kyl so
under the earlybird rule we now turn to
Senator Durbin thanks mister chair mr.
Cavanaugh thank you for returning in
March 2003 Jay Bybee was confirmed to a
seat on the ninth circuit a year and a
half later we learned he had authored
the infamous torture memo when he headed
the Justice Department's Office of Legal
Counsel in the memo a claim the
president has the right to ignore the
law that makes torturer crime and
narrowly defined torture is abuse that
causes pain equivalent to organ failure
or death
the tortured memory was requested by
address to the then White House Counsel
Alberto Gonzalez so clearly the White
House counsel's office knew that mr.
biby had authored the torture memo at
the time of his nomination did you know
that mr. baby authored the torture
memoral or similar memos at the time of
his nomination I know Sara I think
you're referring to the August 1 2002
memo I was not aware of that memo until
there was public disclosure of in the
news media I think in the summer of 2004
the administration is now reputed it
repudiated the memo in retrospect should
the fact that mr. Bobby authored the
torture memos qualified him from
consideration as a nominee senator I
don't think sitting here as a
prospective judge as a nominee to a
court of appeals I should talk about
another sitting judge whether that
person should or should not have been
nominated I just don't think that's a
proper role for me but you see that's
what we're struggling with here we don't
have a number of cases that you've
argued before court because you haven't
we don't have trials that you've taken
to jury verdict because there are none
we are we have to rely on what you have
done with your life and where you have
been to try to determine what your
values are Senator Schumer asked you a
series of questions related to the work
of your life which you didn't feel we're
appropriate to answer and now I'm trying
to plumb that same type of well let's
find out what you really believe in who
you are and every time we get close you
say sorry I can't answer that that is a
problem for a person seeking a seat on
the second highest court in the land I
don't know where to go in questioning
you you don't want to talk about what
you've done that might have any
political implication and frankly when
it comes to legal work there isn't much
to turn to do you see the problem we're
facing senator on that memo I can say
that the administration has repealed
that memo I agree with that decision I
do not believe the analysis and that
memo was correct I think that memo did
not serve the presidency or this
president well and I'm willing to talk
about the memo itself well let me ask
you you were in charge of judicial
nominations or at least involved in
judicial nominations with the White
House and that's why we're going into
this let's go to another nine
and see if you might respond to this in
a September 2003 the president nominated
William Haynes
to be a judge in the Fourth Circuit as
general counsel the Department of
Defense mr. Haynes had been the
architect of the administration's
discredited detention and interrogation
policies for example mr. Haynes
recommended that secretary Rumsfeld
approve the use of abusive interrogation
techniques like threatening detainees
with dogs forced nudity and for forcing
detainees into painful stress positions
during the 108th Congress mr. Haynes
nomination stalled after his involvement
the scandal came to light just this
February the president decided to
renounce him what was your role in the
original Haynes nomination and decision
to ranana Nate it and at the time of the
nomination what did you know about mr.
Haynes role in crafting the
administration's detention and
interrogation policies senator I did not
I was not involved and am not involved
in questions about the rules governing
governing detention of combatants or and
so I did do not have any involvement
with that and with respect to mr. Haynes
nomination I've I know Jim Haynes but it
was not one of the nominations that I
handled I handled a number of
nominations in the counsel's office that
was not one of the ones that I handled
so let me try this approach and see if
we can learn a little more Mannie
Miranda was an employee of the Senate
Judiciary Committee on the Republican
staff and then on the Senate Majority
Leader's staff he hacked into the
computers of the members and staff of
this committee stealing thousands of
documents and memoranda which were then
shared with others were you did you know
Mannie Miranda or do you know him today
I knew Mannie Miranda cuz he was a
member of Senator Hatch's staff and then
senator frist staff working on judicial
nominations did you ever work with him
in terms of judicial nominations he was
part of a group of Senate staffers that
did work on judicial nominations with
people at the Department of Justice in
the White House counsel's office I think
we talked about this last time I did not
know about any memos
from the Democratic side it was not I
did not suspect that had I known or
suspected that I would have immediately
told judge Gonzales so I'm sure would
have immediately talked to chairman
hatch about it did not know about it did
not suspect it he was part however of
the staff of course that worked on
judicial nominations including with on
both sides and my time is up but I think
one of the problems you had with the
American Bar Association when they
downgraded your rating was they thought
you were dismissive of this that you
didn't take this as a serious problem
that a Republican staffer had broken
into the computers of Democratic
senators and their staff was stealing
documents and sharing them with those
who were plotting the strategy for the
White House would you like to respond as
to whether or not you think this was a
serious matter
perhaps criminal senator I don't know
what the American Bar Association said
about that but I know what I told them
and what I've told the committee had I
known or suspected anything like that I
would have immediately told Judge
Gonzales who I'm sure would have
immediately called chairman hatch I know
the matter has been under investigation
in the Senate I know the matter has been
under investigation by a special
prosecutor that is a serious matter and
that is what I said to the American Bar
Association and that's what I'm saying
to this committee so that's my view on
the matter thank you mmm thank you very
much
Senator Durbin by Senator Coburn Thank
You mr. chairman uh I just wanted to put
a few points into the record of the 12
members of the DC Circuit and the two
seniors none have as broad of experience
in terms of measurement points as our
nominee here today only five have
clerked on the federal appeals court out
of the 14 only four of clerked on the
Supreme Court only six have argued
before the Court of Appeals only five
have argued before the Supreme Court
only seven have had editorial positions
on law review only four has had previous
judicial experience if everybody that's
on there now only four have had previous
judicial experience and only four had
any
lady branch experience again I I want to
address issues out in the open I I think
what's happening here today I'm somewhat
embarrassed about we have somebody who's
obviously qualified the ABA says he's
qualified he hadn't downgraded he's
recognized as qualified
he's extremely well-qualified and well
qualified this time he's well qualified
with a minority extremely well-qualified
or qualified and well qualified but what
it requires is qualified and if you look
at the ABS position of what qualified is
and let me read it for you should we
have any questions regarding that means
that the nominee meets the committee's
very this is qualified meets that the
means that the nominee meets the
committee's very high standards with
respect to integrity professional
competence judicial temperament and that
the committee believes that the nominee
will be able to perform satisfactory all
of the duties and responsibilities
required by the high office of the
federal judge everybody on that ABA says
you're qualified and I just read what it
means the idea that we're fishing around
because we don't like something the Bush
administration has done or we're going
to imply and impune the integrity of
somebody who's been in a position of
responsibility offered his good services
to fulfill the requirements of the
executive branch and anything you don't
like about the executive branch you're
going to try to tie to this gentleman is
improper it also is dismissive of our
our open form of government and is
exactly again I'll say again exactly
what the American people are sick of
partisan sniping that's not about the
issues but trying to score point and
trying to undermine somebody's integrity
who has absolute integrity on these
issues they've answered the questions
we're here we're here to give a second
look at somebody who's already answered
the questions and there is precedent to
not give answers to questions about
certain privileged communications within
the White House
that does not mean
that those are necessarily devious or
wrong it means you protect the the the
office of the presidency that's an
appropriate role there's nothing wrong
with that I will have one question for
you
why do you want to be a federal judge
Sarah I want to be a federal judge
because I know from experience and
through my upbringing the role of the
courts and protecting the rights and
liberties of the people I know how
essential the rule of all law is to our
country I know how the independence of
our federal judiciary is central to our
constitutional form of government I
think based on my experience in my
background I can make a contribution to
the administration of justice I think I
can be a good judge and it's part of my
commitment to public service that I've
carried out for most of the 16 years
since I graduated from law school do you
think it makes any difference on your
ability to be an appellate judge in this
country which side of the issue you were
on on on the impeachment or which side
of the issue you were on any of these
issues that have been right your
personal opinion when you've testified
that you're not going to allow personal
opinion to interfere and your your
interpretation of the law and the
Independence of the judiciary it doesn't
have a bearing senator I absolutely
believe in the idea that judges are
neutral and impartial and that whatever
activities may have occurred in
someone's past life in terms of
government activities those are good
experience to have to become a good
judge but it also is true once you put
on the black robe you're impartial and
you represent the law it's justice
Kennedy used to tell us the essential
neutrality of the law and I think that
is some principle that I would seek to
follow were I to be confirmed to the DC
Circuit Court of Appeals I think it's
essential to our entire system of
government there's no such thing on the
courts of a Republican judge or
democratic judge once you're on the
court all the judges are there
representing the justice system
representing the idea of justice thank
you my times experiment Thank You
senator
weren't senator Feinstein I'm happy to
yield to Senator Kennedy my
understanding is you want to do next
I appreciate that we've got this health
legislation on the floor now which we're
trying to work work through if it's
convenient for the senator from
California just to take the time I thank
the thank the chair
judge congratulations you mr. Cavanaugh
for the getting gaining the president's
confidence the circuit court as you know
has such a special jurisdiction in terms
of so many different areas of
legislation that we passed the National
Labor Relations Board the relationship
of workers and what happens to work as
discrimination against workers in the
workplace environmentally kinds of
issues they're working through and their
judgments on so many of these end up
being the law and so if you go on to the
Supreme Court and we have seen very
interesting trends that are taking place
in the district court and so that this
has a special relevancy and importance
so that's least why we spend as much
time as we do on this particular and
nomination now just on the I want to
just fairly focus in on this issue again
of a torture and rendition your role
there it's on the Armed Services
Committee and we've spent a lot of time
we've had 10 investigations of torture
and none of them have revealed what
we're constantly seeing revealed now
with newer reports that have come on up
in the newspapers and exposed by Freedom
of Information report so it's something
that's and we have a private policy of
rendition which is of Norma's concern to
too many of us and we also know that the
mr. Gonzalez was in touch with mr. Bybee
when he was over at OLC I mean we've
gone through all of this this was all
through the Gonzalez during when mr.
Gonzalez was up for attorney general
and we also know that Hanes was in touch
with the White House at that time good
chance that he was in touch with OLC so
this is the background have you ever
previously be as you will know in that
vibey memorandum effectively said that
if you go on out you're in the military
service or on the contract and you go
out and torture someone it doesn't make
any difference how badly you torture or
what pain you inflict as long as your
purpose is to get information rather
than to hurt an individual the you're
going to be vindicated in terms of any
kind of protections I mean effectively
and that also was included in the Bible
and mr. Gonzales repudiated it when he
came up before the community committee
to be Attorney General is this the first
time you've ever made a comment on the
Bybee memoranda you responded to Senator
Durbin and said that in sort of a
follow-up question that you did not
agree with the reasoning of the
rationale for it is this the first time
that you've ever said anything about
that I believe it is it's possible I've
said something to uh people I work with
but I this is the first time sort of
I've been questioned about it but you
haven't prior to this time ever made a
comment or or statement to to others
indicating that you found that it
particularly offensive because it was
it's been a major issue an issue in
question out there please senator I know
that Judge Gonzales in the summer of
2004 had a press conference where the
memo was repealed and talked about this
issue I think also does confirmation
hearing in 2005 he said he disagreed I
believe with a with the legal analysis
and there that the legal analysis in
there was incorrect and so I know
members of the administration have
repudiated that memorandum or at least
the legal analysis memory and you your
your testimony is you had nothing with
the promotion of by be to the Ninth
Circuit that correct that was not one of
the nominations I worked on and and I
knew he was of course being nominated
but I didn't know some of the issues
that you're talking about well then
you're saying that you didn't know that
he wrote what we know as the Bible
memoranda at the time that he was being
considered for the for the
I first learned of the existence of that
memo I think when there was a Washington
Post story in the summer of 2004 and I
think that's the pretty sure that's the
first time I learned anything about the
August 1 memo ok and for mr. for mr.
Haynes have you have you expressed an
opinion in terms of the legal counsel
for the Defense Department for promotion
I understand you don't handle you have
not handled the Haynes nomination
that's correct senator and in terms of
my portfolio in the counsel's office it
involved a lot of civil justice issues
worked on nominations some ethics issues
separation separation of powers issues
it did not involve the kinds of issues
you're raising in your questions well
aren't most of those I mean the except
for the most of those issues class
actions insurance or form are most of
those handled in the various Department
so were they they aren't those sort of
policy issues handled in the department
are the those are the issues that you
were working on I worked I would say
primarily on judicial nominations in the
wake of September 11th there are a
number of civil justice issues that I
worked on including the terrorism
insurance litigation goods just finally
on the the documents that were taken
here from the from the committee and
that you have the familiarity Randee
documents and you've indicated that you
in reviewing them had no understanding
or awareness that they had been taken
didn't been stolen have you ever gone
back now that you are aware of it and
seeing what decisions you may or might
not have taken on the basis of documents
that were illegally taken to see whether
you may have made some judgments a
decision to reach certain conclusions
now that you know that they were not
properly taken have you ever thought
well I ought to go back I might have
made some judgments and decisions when I
was in the in in the in the working for
the President and I ought to take a look
at this since you know that these
documents now we're taken have you ever
thought about that
sarin there's a very important premise
in your question I think's incorrect
which is I didn't know about the memos
or see the memos that I think you're
describing so I think oh you never saw
or any of those you know senator that's
correct I don't know I'm not aware of
the memos I never saw such memos that I
think you're referring to I mean I don't
know what the universe of memos might be
but I do know that I never seen any
memos was not aware of any such memo so
I just want to correct that premise that
I think was in your question okay
that time is that mister Thank You
senator Kennedy on the Republican side
we have in sequence senator Graham's
senator sessions senator Cornyn and
Senator Kyl on the Democratic side we
have a knock question senator Feinstein
and Senator Feingold I had senator
Feinstein ahead of senator Kennedy on
the list yes I yield yeah I just want to
be sure that the questions correct is
sometimes judgmental senator Feinstein
was here first but she left for a while
senator Kennedy came but at any rate
senator Feinstein yielded but I want to
thank you I wanted that known that that
was the list that I had and now senator
Graham famous chairman I have one I want
to congratulate you for having the
hearing because I think it's appropriate
it is a lifetime appointment that people
be able to ask questions and he'd be
able to answer within the his ability to
do so without compromising what he
believes to be his ethics or any proper
role he may have played as a lawyer
do you believe you were treated fairly
by the ABA senator the American Bar
Association has rated me three times
when you get to the directly to the
question but I'm going to give you some
background if I could I've been rated
three times by the American Bar
Association and each time there are 14
individual reviews conducted by members
of the committee so there have been a
total of 42 separate reviews can
to me based on interviews with lots of
people and what review of lots of record
all 42 have found that I'm well
qualified or qualified to serve on the
DC Circuit Court yes so I'm pleased with
that and I'm proud of that and to the
extent and none of the 42 has found that
I'm not qualified in you know I think
the chair of the committee yesterday
said that there's not been a breath of
anyone saying that I'm not Claus
qualified so I'm proud and pleased with
the 42 of 42 so do you think you were
fairly treated Sarah I think sitting
here as a nominee I would prefer not to
talk about Mike my you know about the
American Bar Association other to say
that I'm pleased and proud to have 42 or
42 rating me well qualified or qualified
based on your going through that
experience would you recommend that we
continue to consult the ABA when it
comes to judges senator again I I'm
pleased and proud of the ratings there
in the future maybe we'll look back and
have some observations but right now I
don't I don't think I have any
observation Stahl for the committee
about the American Bar Association yeah
your time at the what else you dealt
with I think you just strived your job
one of these constitutional questions
that we're trying to wrestle with here
is the inherent authority of the
President
at a time of war versus any designated
role of the judiciary or the Congress in
general do you agree with justice
Jackson's evaluation in the Youngstown
steel case that the president or the
executive branch is that their strongest
maximum power when they have concurrence
of the legislative body I agree
completely with that senator very
specific question do you believe that at
a time of war the Congress has the
ability to amend past the Uniform Code
of Military Justice and that not
infringe on the president's inherit
authority inherent authority as
commander in chief
senator that sounds like a specific
hypothetical that could come before the
court saw it hesitate to give an answer
in terms of justice Jackson's framework
that of course for a half-century has
been the guiding framework I think it's
a work of genius that opinion in terms
of setting out the different categories
of presidential power and congressional
power in in times of war and otherwise
in terms of as you say category one when
the President and Congress work together
that's when the powers at the strongest
in category two that's what they call
the Twilight Zone in the in the opinion
and then in category three where a
president acts against the express or
implied will of Congress that's where
the president's power is at its lowest
ad and raises some very serious
constitutional questions according to
justice Jackson I think that's an
exceptional opinion that has guided
American law the relationship between
Congress and the executive for about a
half century and it's really been the
foundation of these kinds of issues that
I know you and the committee have been
working on finally and in you don't want
to answer it you don't have to but are
you Republican if so why Sarah I am a
registered Republican I as I said before
to Senator Coburn I believe very much
that it's good to have judges who've
participated in government that's been
part of our experience in the in the
past to have judges on the DC Circuit
who've participated in the executive
branch you've worked in the executive
branch judges on the Supreme Court
specifically to answer your question I
when I was first registering to vote
President Reagan was president and I
agreed with him on on some issues and
registered Republican and the first
election and I guess 1984 was the first
one I voted in thank you very much
senator Graham senator Feinstein thank
you very much mr. chairman let me just
say this this is a difficult nomination
first of all you're very young which is
I think a blessing for you but in in
terms of an appellate judge I think it
is a detriment
obviously you've had a good education
you've done well you spent a lot of your
life in at least a semi political
capacity the question comes up how can
you assure us that you will be fair
would you recuse yourself from any
judgment that concerned this
administration without a record either
as a trial lawyer or as a judge it's
very difficult for some of us to know
what kind of a judge you would be and
whether you can move away from the
partisanship into that arena of
objectivity and fairness Sarah thank you
for the question I think in the past on
the DC Circuit and and on the Supreme
Court and on other courts of appeals
other than the DC Circuit prior
government experience and the
legislative branch or the executive
branch has been seen as a very valuable
asset whether it was judge Abner Mikva
or judge a Patricia Wald judge John
Roberts on the DC Circuit Judge Merrick
garland who President Clinton appointed
to the DC Circuit that's that kind of
experience has been seen as very
valuable experience and valuable
background and of course the question I
think only four of the last twenty-one
judges on the DC Circuit have actually
had prior judicial experience or the
norm on the DC Circuit in fact the
overwhelming norm is for the judges on
the DC Circuit since 1977 not to have
had prior judicial experience what
they've had usually is government
experience in the legislative branches
or the executive branches and your
question really goes to how do you
assess someone's record I think that's
done through an assessment of going back
in my case
16 years of my career and looking at the
kinds of things I've done in the staff
secretary's office now where I'm an
honest broker where I have to be fair
and even-handed in the kind of role I
performed for the president some of the
work I've done in the counsel's office
on judges have worked with your office
and center box
office in the past on judges I know in
and worked closely on that when I was in
private practice working on not just
institutional clients but pro bono cases
one of my proudest cases I worked on a
pro bono case for synagogue in my home
county that was seeking to build a new
low-key building a new location some of
the neighbors didn't want it there I
represented them they won in federal
district court in the independent
counsel's office I know senator that
that's controversial and that's raised
some questions and I think in that
office my record shows that I was fair
and conducted myself responsibly I've
written an article about some reforms
that I think would help avoid some of
the problems that I think we're systemic
and the independent counsel I'm running
out of time
answer the recusal question I'm the
recusal question I know that there will
be issues of recusal that I'll face
their standards in place under 28 USC
455 and I will analyze those closely
were I to be confirmed to be adjudged
there will be some difficult questions I
do not want to prejudge how I would rule
on any recusal motion or how I would
handle any particular case but I do know
senator that it will be an issue in
certain cases I pledge to you that I'll
take that seriously that I'll study the
precedence of people like myself who've
come to the bench that I'll talk to my
colleagues where I to be confirmed and
that I'll make the judgment responsibly
I've pledged that to you as you look
back at the Kenneth Starr investigation
today I just read the op-ed you wrote in
1999 what are your thoughts what do you
think on the Independent Counsel office
investigation in general I think a
couple things senator first of all I
think it was in retrospect probably a
mistake for judge Starr to be assigned
additional investigations after the
initial whitewater Madison investigation
so he got new jurisdiction over our
travel office matter and FBI files
matter and eventually the Lewinsky
matter I think it would have been better
in
retrospect for judge Starr to handle
what he was initially assigned for it
and if there was a new special counsel
needed in those other matters for new
people to be appointed by it
by adding to the jurisdiction it created
the impression that Judge Starr was
somehow the permanent special
investigator of the administration he
was assigned a very specific matter so
that's one thing in retrospect and
frankly even at the time that I thought
was a concern I think the way the report
was released was a real problem I
thought that at the time and I think the
way that was released did not serve
anyone well and I've written in my Law
Journal article about the problems with
prosecutorial reports the way people's
reputations are damaged so I've proposed
some real reforms there I also know that
it was a very serious matter in terms of
the underlying issue in the in 1998 in
terms of the things that members of this
body Wade and the members of the House
of Representatives weighed in that Judge
Wright dealt with in terms of the
contempt motion that she dealt with so
there was a serious underlying matter
there as I believe that I believe that
the there was the judge star tried to do
with thoroughly but again to go back to
the core problem I think there was too
much jurisdiction added to judge Starr
that created a mistake in public
impression that harmed the credibility
of the investigation Thank You mr.
chairman
mr. Cavanaugh thank you for your
thoughts on to senator Feinstein's
question about the Starr investigation I
think you provided some good insight and
I think that probably is a reason why
your reputation as a member of that in
the prosecutorial team and was very high
and people had a clear impression that
you were a cool head and a wise member
of that team and that's the reputation
I've heard and I can see why you had
that I would note that Ken Starr was
form Solicitor General of the United
States a man of impeccable integrity
extraordinary legal skill and anyone
would have been proud to answer his call
to serve him looking at the ABA
evaluation I think first of all you are
you did extremely well extraordinarily
well they ever be rated well qualified
by them in the sense that you were
relatively young and we're working in an
administration of the Bush
administration you were given the
highest possible rating by them and
you've been there now in a less legal
capacity and and a few more new members
and a few members of decided to give you
the qualified rating instead of
well-qualified rating but I don't think
that is a big issue in fact I would
quote mr. tobert steven kolb or the
chairman of the committee on judiciary
this is what he said in our conversation
with him just the other day in this
telephone conversation he said this
quote let me underscore we did not find
him unqualified there's not a breath in
that report or anything any earlier
report we found him qualified minority
well-qualified what I said at the
in is what in fact many people said that
he has a solid reputation for integrity
intellectual capacity a lot of people
refer to him as brilliant and an
excellent writing and analytical ability
those are great skills to bring to the
Court of Appeals there's no question
about that but quote you wouldn't object
to them saying that about you would you
just say we'll pass over that then he
went on to say this quote he has found
to have high integrity he is found to be
brilliant he is a very skilled writer
and legal analyst he has those
components he has those skills that will
serve him well certainly on a federal
court close quote
so I then he goes on the site quote it
is true I think maybe the senator
Hatch's question quote it is true
there's not a single not qualified vote
in the picture close quote I think ABA
writing whether it's as high as it could
be and and all of them didn't vote you
well-qualified the highest possible
rating but I they did write you are
qualified and the chairman of the
committee gave some very interesting
insights I think I would just like to
note on the aged question that you do
you are six years older I believe then
judge Stapleton when he was appointed to
the bench the Court of Appeals in six
years older than Judge Kozinski when he
was appointed to the bench both of whom
you clerked for I think somebody think
the chairman made that earlier and
Justice Kennedy was appointed to the
Ninth Circuit three years younger than
you are today I think those are
qualities that I think other qualities
are at stake here let me just say this
about my thinking of how you evaluate a
nominee that is you consider the entire
breadth of the gifts and graces they
bring to the job and if a person has
less I like a person who's been in
at practice I think that's fine but if a
person doesn't have private practice or
a lot of it you a partner in one of the
country's best law firms that's ought to
be some private practice experience but
whether you had a great deal of that
experience or not other factors are
considered in here you were editor of
the Yale Law Journal one of the editors
of that you clerk but to Circuit Judges
both of whom have testified for you the
first one you he said you should be a
judge he saw that in you when you first
clerked for him and advised you that is
a career path so you work for - all
right Court of Appeals judges you sat at
their right hand the two judges who hold
a very position you will be holding
today and then you are given the rare
honor of clerking for a justice on the
US Supreme Court Justice Kennedy judges
considered a moderate middle-of-the-road
judge I guess and you served under his
leadership so those are things that I
think are extraordinarily important and
you serve in the Solicitor General's
Office of the United States that's the
the greatest law office in the world
where you represent the United States
before the federal appellate courts in
the country arguing cases before the
court that bear courts that you sit upon
as well as arguing cases before the US
Supreme Court an honor bear a few
lawyers have so I think it's a good
experience and extraordinary academic
record mr. chairman and I believe he
should be confirmed thank you very much
senator sessions a senator Feingold
arrived earlier but as departed Senator
Leahy arrived later and his ranking and
Senator Leahy has agreed to be able to
use senator Feingold go ahead I'm after
this these tough tough questions that
senator sessions has been asking for the
nominee just sits as canonized I'm
overwhelmed by that's all yield to I
think you should have been here earlier
to hear senator Hatch's tough question
senator Feingold you only asked tough
questions the Democratic coordinates the
other well this is a second time around
I think both the Chairman and the
ranking member and I thank you mr.
chairman for holding this hearing it was
obviously the right thing to do given
that it's been nearly two years since
the first hearing and frankly in light
of mr. Kavanagh is in complete responses
to written questions even though he
delayed providing those response for
seven months
among those written questions were
several questions that I submitted
concerning ethical issues that came up
in connection with the nominations of
three judges who I believe mr. Cavanaugh
assisted as part of his duties in the
White House Charles Pickering who
received a recess appointment and
subsequently retired and D Brooke Smith
and Ron Clark who are currently on the
bench in his November 2004 responses mr.
Cavanaugh essentially refused to answer
my questions I wrote him a letter on
Friday explaining why I believe these
questions are appropriate and asking him
to supplement his responses late
yesterday I received a response not from
mr. Cavanaugh but mister from mr.
mashella at the Justice Department that
said the following quote as you know
chairman Spector is scheduled hearing
mr. Cavanaugh's nomination on may 9 2006
at that time mr. Cavanaugh will be
available to respond to questions from
all senators on the committee unquote
mr. chairman first I'd like to put a
record in the record a copy of my letter
and mr. Michelle Jersey without
objection it will be made a part of the
record
hey mr. Minelli mr. Cavanaugh I assumed
you were consulted and approved of mr.
Marshalls response I hope that you will
now respond to my questions here's the
first one for which I sought an
additional response the Senate's
consideration of Judge Charles
Pickering's nomination to the Fifth
Circuit the Judiciary Committee learned
that he solicited and collected letters
of support from lawyers who had appeared
in his courtroom and practiced in his
district it later became apparent that
some of these lawyers had cases pending
before him when they wrote the letters
at Judge Pickering requested professor
Stephen gillers of NYU Law School and
quote judge Pickering solicitation
creates the appearance of impropriety in
violation of Canon two of the code of
conduct for us judges the impropriety
becomes particularly acute if lawyers
are litigants with matters currently
pending before the judge were solicited
on
so serve my first question is this did
you know the judge Pickering a plan to
solicit letters of support in this
manner before he did so and if not when
did you become aware of the judge
Pickering had solicited these letters of
support the answer to the first question
senator is no this was not a one of the
judicial nominees that I was primarily
handling I became aware of suggestions
of this sort assume at some time during
the proceedings probably when it was
raised I don't know if it was raised in
the media or raised by the Senate in the
first instance without commenting on the
facts and circumstances that matters I
really don't know the facts and
circumstances if want to judge asks a
lawyer who's got a case before him or
her to do something that does put the
lawyer in a very awkward position
and makes it difficult for the lawyer
say no so just in terms of a
hypothetical situation that there is a
situation there again I don't know the
facts and circumstances of what was
going on there I only heard about it
really from either the media from when
the members of this committee were
talking about that issue I'd like to
know if you think that judge Pickering's
conduct was consistent with the ethical
obligations of a federal judge senator I
don't know if there's been fact-finding
on what his conduct was in terms of the
hypothetical situation of a judge asking
a lawyer there's a case before him or
her to do something I know that that
raises some questions again I don't know
the facts and circumstances of what
judge Pickering thought I've given you a
couple my general principle it's a good
general principle but the facts are
pretty clear I don't think he denied
that he solicited these letters and that
these were individuals that appeared
before him there was some debate about
the significance of it but am i off
track and suggesting that it looks like
at least those set of facts whether you
think they occurred in this case would
be a violation of the Code of Ethics
I hesitate to comment on another
judicial nominee again a senator I'm
happy to state a general principle that
I believe in again let's go with the
general principle then if the judge is
up for nomination he solicits letters
from lawyers who have cases before him
isn't the general principle that that
would be a violation of the code of
ethics I think I think that raises some
questions that war
some further questions to find out what
happened hmm you have no I see my time
is up thank you thank you very much
senator Feingold the next questioner is
a Senator Cornyn thank you this chairman
welcome back mr. Kavanagh Thank You
senator the second hearing two years
after roughly after your first hearing
and we've heard learned lots change in
your personal life but I don't think a
lots changed in terms of your
professional record as it would relate
to your qualifications to serve on the
DC Circuit mr. Chairman I have a
statement that I'd like to make part of
the record without objection thank you I
want to ask a little bit about some of
the questions that you have been asked
here today the rationale given for a
second hearing that was requested is
that there might be some new information
that would be revealed that might change
the minds of some of those who have
previously expressed some skepticism as
to whether you should be confirmed or
not but I think this is my observation
not yours but I think what we've seen is
part of a what has become a fairly
common practice in the course of these
hearings and that is to ask you
questions the nominee questions that
they cannot or should not ethically
answer and that coupled frequently with
demanding documents which are not in
your possession in which you cannot
produce because they're the subject of a
privilege and then there's course then
the claim that you are somehow too
extreme out of the mainstream
unfortunately I don't think those are
the kinds of questions and the kind of
approach that's designed really to
reveal
very much in the way of information
that's helpful to us and make decisions
but rather part of a plan to try to
damage your nomination and to justify a
no vote or perhaps even a filibuster of
your nomination on the Senate floor
you've been asked about everything from
the Clinton impeachment to torture to
rendition policy to judge Pickering it
strikes me that rather than finding out
about your experience and background and
your qualifications as an individual
that there's been some attempt to
associate you with other issues of which
with which you have no knowledge and
perhaps as you say have not had any
contact so I know that chairman Specter
had agreed to do this second hearing
based on the representation that there
might be some bona fide attempt to
elicit information that would actually
change some votes and attitudes but
unfortunately I don't see that happening
in the course of this hearing so far
I guess one can always hope one of the
courses you know I met you a number of
years ago when I was Attorney General of
Texas and had the honor to represent my
state in an argument before the United
States Supreme Court and that was a
Santa Fe Independent School District
versus doe which involved a question of
whether school children could
voluntarily offer a prayer or an
inspirational saying before school
football games in Texas and as you know
that the court ultimately ruled against
that voluntary student prayer in the
case and Chief Justice Rehnquist in
dissent said that the court's ruling
exhibited hostility to all things
religious in public life and I'm very
concerned about
that because I do believe that the
founders thought that the the posture of
the government with regard to religious
expression should be one of neutrality
not hostility I realize as a lower court
judge you're going to be bound by the
Supreme Court's precedents but I wonder
if you would address the issue of
religious liberty and religious speech
and so far as how you believe in your
position as a circuit court judge how
you would approach those issues senator
if I were confirmed to be a DC Circuit
Judge I would of course follow the
precedent of the Santa Fe case that case
addressed a question that had been left
open and Ali versus Weissman case in
1992 in that case a school-sponsored
there was a school-sponsored prayer to
graduation ceremony where the where the
government was actually involved and one
of the questions that was left open was
what happens if a student or a private
speaker participates in a school event
as a private speaker and in the Santa Fe
case I think the court concluded based
on the facts and circumstances of the
case that it could be attributed to the
school and so was a violation of the
Establishment Clause I think the overall
area represents a tension the Supreme
Court has attempted to resolve
throughout the years in terms of
facilitating the free exercise of
religion without crossing the
Establishment Clause lines that the
court has set out for many years now I
know that the court in recent years has
made clear in a number of cases that
private religious speech religious
people religious organizations cannot be
or should not be discriminated against
and that treating religious speech
religious people religious organizations
equally in other words on a level
playing field with non religious
organizations is not a violation of the
Establishment Clause in the in past
years there had been some suggestion
that treating religious organizations
the same way in the public square as
non-religious or
could sometimes be a violation of the
Establishment Clause I think the courts
really gone to a principle of equality
of treatment does not ordinarily violate
the Establishment Clause again a quality
of treatment of religious speech
religious people religious organizations
equality in the public square that's
been something we've seen over the last
it's a decade or a little more at the
CNF a case again but the issue there was
that although it was a private speaker
the school the court found this on all
the facts and circumstances that it was
attributed to the school and therefore
fell within the prohibition and Lee
versus Weisman Thank You senator Cornyn
de Kavanagh we're almost to the two-hour
mark would you care to take a breath
I'm okay mr. chairman Senator Leahy
Sharon I have an opening statement I
won't date but I'd like to put in the
record without objection your opening
statement will be later part of the
record I'll also note for the record in
that I realized we have the president is
my school foreign judge Terrence Boyle
and I've suggested the calling the
president withdraw Terrence Boyles name
the North Carolina Police Benevolent
Association North Carolina troopers
associated Police Benevolent Association
South Carolina Virginia National
Association of police organizations many
others civil rights groups others have
opposed it I could think of an awful lot
of reasons why he should withdraw it
that's not in the province of what mr.
Cavanaugh has to worry about but I would
hope rather than go through a needless
exercise the terrors Boyles name be
withdrawn especially in light of the
recent allegations of an ethical conduct
and mr. Cavanaugh you're aware of the
somewhat unique we originally understood
to be a be a to testify here today
that had been agreed to but apparently
that was done by a phone call Monday
well most of us were out of town are you
aware of what would transpire in that
phone call senator I'm Jeff seeing the
transcript I have not read the whole
transcript I've seen some excerpts of
the transcript that were reported in
news articles as well as other excerpts
that is I've asked that the transcript
to be made part of the record if it's
not already there without objection and
will be made part of the record when
they they spoke of you is not having
handled a case to verdict is that is
that right you never tried a case to
verdict or have you that is correct
Center I have not been a trial lawyer I
think I'm in the same boat there with
people like Chief Justice Roberts I'm
just asking about you I'm not we we had
a hearing on Chief Justice Roberts I
voted for him for chief justice and I
voted for him for the DC Circuit I know
Chief Justice Roberts you're not Chief
Justice Roberts you have your own
qualities so let's just talk about you
it's it that's alright if you don't mind
sir I have not tried a case divert I've
been have you it also said your
litigation experiences over the years
was in the company as senior counsel is
that correct I've argued many cases on
my own Seren Leahy have argued in the
Supreme Court of the United States I've
argued in their eighth circuit I've
argued twice in the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals well you did you do those as the
sole person arguing yes senator thank
you Sarah let me just add one thing in
one DC Circuit Kate that the case there
were two counsel that argued on our side
so I just want to be clear on that but I
also I argue for myself on it was a
government attorney client I was going
to ask you about that but you've
clarified it thank you
why did you take seven months
so the written questions you were given
after your hearing last time Center I
take responsibility for that and I'm
happy to answer any additional questions
why did you take 7 months sent right
again I take responsibility for that and
and of course you take responsibility
for it obviously they're your answers
but why 7 months senator if there was a
I think I take responsibility for that I
think I had a misunderstanding which is
my responsibility I'm happy to answer
additional questions today that you may
have or other members that can committee
may have again I thought was a
misunderstanding said all right I take
responsibility for mr. Cavanaugh not
playing games I'm just asking you I'm
asking you a question
yes I you know one of the I won't go
into one of the ways one judge describes
your conduct and in court I began to
think the perhaps he was right but I
take responsibility fine that's kind of
a catch-all everybody says that I just
asked you why I mean is that that
difficult senator my understanding was
that the timeline for the questions was
to make sure they were in before the end
of the congressional session because
there was going to be no further action
on my nomination in the committee I met
that timeline you know from a later
letter that members of the committee
that you signed it appears that that
that item misunderstanding of that I
take responsibility for that and I'm
happy to answer any questions you have
the what was your reaction
well as staff secretary you see
virtually every piece of paper that goes
to the president is that correct that's
on many issues yes senator not
everything you saw did you see documents
relating to the president's NSA
warrantless wiretapping program senator
I learned of that program when there was
a New York Times story were the reports
of that program when there was a New
York Times story that came over the wire
I think on a Thursday night in mid
December of last got seen anything or
her had you heard anything about it
prior to the New York Times article no
nothing at all nothing at all
and what about the documents relating to
the administration's policies and
practice on torture did you see anything
about that or had you right did you
first hear about that when you write
about in the paper I think on with
respect to though legal justifications
or the policies relating to the
treatment of detainees I was not aware
of any issues on that or the legal memos
that subsequent came out to the summer
sometime in 2004 when there started to
be news reports on that this was not
part of my docket either in the
counsel's office or as staff secretary I
have more questions my time is up and
I'll save them for the next round
thank you senator Kyl Thank You senator
Leahy's senator Carr Thank You mr.
chairman just on that last point I
gather that in the briefings to the
president by the CIA and other members
of the Intelligence Agency there were a
lot of things that did not come across
your desk that they were given directly
to the president is that correct that's
correct
I was not here unfortunately to hear the
the introduction of you but I was
impressed by what was said it was
written down for me and I am and very
impressed that these judges for whom you
clerked would have such a high opinion
of you a judge Kozinski which who is one
of the finest judges that I that I know
said that you were one of the finest
clerks he's had and a breadth of mind
and breadth of vision and
a great sense of humanity and I think
judge Stapleton a judges dream as a law
clerk and that you understand the role
of precedent exceptionally
well-qualified in terms of experience
superb candidate and so on I think those
are important because they represent the
opinion of someone for whom we have a
great deal of regard as sitting
appellate judges of you and I think
that's an important qualification there
have been a couple of questions raised
about this matter of qualification one
the ABA rating and and to your relative
age and I just want to talk about a
couple of those here as I understand it
from mr. Stephen toe burrs statement
that this entire difference between
qualified and well qualified boils down
and I'll quote it from his statement
page 7 quote it is at its most basic the
difference between the highest standard
and a very high standard and so it seems
to me that for us to try to make some
distinction and and somehow deem you not
qualified based upon that very fine
distinction is to establish a standard
that we have never applied in this
committee in the past may I just ask you
how many of the the people that rated
you were there again who either rated
you qualified or well-qualified and was
there anyone who dissented from either
of those two rank rankings senator from
the ABA ratings there were 42 individual
reviews conducted over the course of
three years and all 42 found me well
qualified or qualified to sit on the DC
Circuit so this seems to me in terms of
making a decision on this committee a
distinction without a difference I'll
just quote from page nine of and then
move on to the next point after talking
about your breath to experience
consistently praiseworthy statements and
so on here's mr. Tolbert said the
nominee enjoys a solid reputation for
integrity intellectual capacity and
writing and analytical ability and it
seems to me that that pretty well
answers that point now this matter of
age is is something that perhaps we
should take a look at as
was noted several important nominees
Justice Kennedy appointed to the Ninth
Circuit when he was 38 judge Kozinski 35
judge Stapleton 35 I also note the
current chief of the Ninth Circuit my
Circuit Mary Schroeder 38 when she was
appointed judge Sam Alito age 40 all
younger than you are but it seems to me
that we could actually take some some
solace from your age based upon the
experience in this committee mr.
chairman we have to look no further than
a distinguished ranking member of the
committee and and the senior senator
from Massachusetts and the second
ranking member of this committee to note
that in all three cases of Senator Biden
Senator Kennedy and Senator Leahy
elected at the age of 30 30 and 34 and
look what great things each of them
accomplished from from those early
beginnings and may I interrupt each of
them has almost a lifetime appointment
[Laughter]
but I public and state and and it
certainly makes the point that at the
constitutional age that is the age at
which the constitutional says one must
be qualified we've elected to the United
States Senate and confirmed to the
courts of appeals and even the United
States Supreme Court some incredibly
qualified individuals who have acquitted
themselves very well and I count all of
the colleagues whom I've mentioned here
in that in that category and therefore
it seems to me that if that's any
precedent we have nothing but the
greatest expectations for your service
on the Court of Appeals and I'm very
proud to add my voice to those who are
in support of that nomination thank you
Thank You senator Kyl senator brownback
thanks mr. chairman and welcome mr.
Cavanaugh appreciate your meeting with
me I think I'm only one of two people
that are on the committee now that
weren't on the committee when you
previously or your first time you came
in front of the committee
appreciated your your time that you've
spent with me answering my questions I
appreciate the information you provided
to my staff and and that's been very
helpful in my decision-making process
with you I want to ask a couple of
questions that I find important you may
have answered them in in other types of
settings but I wanted to look at and
they're there general but I think that
it's sort of thing that the we on the
legislative situs need to get out in the
open for our decision-making your view
of the Constitution and the issue of
judicial restraint these were key items
on judge Roberts and Alito's hearings
they're important than going to a
Circuit Court just if you would you've
probably answered this already and I
apologize if you hadn't I hadn't heard
it but just give me your view of the
Constitution as a document itself is
this a can you put yourself in a
category do you have a view that's
established as a living document as a
strict constructionist of the the
Constitution itself Sarah I believe very
much in interpreting text as it's
written and not seeking to impose one's
own personal policy preferences into the
text of the document I believe very much
in judicial restraint recognizing the
primary policymaking role of the
legislative branch and our
constitutional democracy I believe very
much as a prospective inferior court
judge where I to be confirmed in
following the Supreme Court precedent
strictly and absolutely once as a lower
court judge I think that's very
important for the stability of our three
level system for lower courts to
faithfully follow Supreme Court
precedent and so that's something that I
think is very important in terms of the
independence of the judiciary I think
that's something that's the hallmark of
our judiciary the hallmark of our system
that judges are independent from the
legislative branch and independent from
the executive branch
think that's central to my understanding
of proper judicial role in terms of tax
precedent restraint independence those
the kinds of principles that I think
would inform my approach to judicial
decision-making were I to be confirmed
we go specifically an issue of judicial
restraint if I could on on that
particular area as I believe it as Judge
Roberts noted that that's the where
numbers are concerned about areas that
the court has gotten involved in in
recent years and that that has really
led to the public's concern about the
judiciary in general because it keeps
getting into more and more areas that
many of us thought were the proper
purview of the legislative process
rather than the judicial branch and so
the judicial activism charge then gets
gets put forward and several have said
well the key restraint on the judiciary
is the judiciary itself and yet if the
judiciary doesn't show restraint on what
cases that it brings up or what cases
that it takes you know the Congress is
left to try to act on limiting review by
the courts to try to amend the
Constitution to change the court
interpretation all of which are
difficult things to do there was a case
recently we just held the flag burning
amendment that passed through the
subcommittee that I chair and that's in
response to the court saying that you
can burn the flag as a statement of free
speech and it was as a response to a
court that overturned a prior Court
opinion saying you couldn't do it it's
those sort of things I think really
frustrate the the public and then the
issue of marriage that's coming up that
has been long-standing issue for
legislative process coming now working
through the court system do you have a
viewpoint on issues say as as marriage
and the determination and the definition
of that is that something that the the
court should establish or is it is it
left to the legislative bodies senator
that's the kind of question that were I
to be confirmed could come before me so
I'd hesitate
to talk about a specific issue in terms
of your general principle about judicial
activism I do think that some of the
worst moments in Supreme Court's history
been moments of judicial activism like
the Dred Scott case like the Lochner
case where the court went outside its
proper bounds in my judgment in
interpreting clauses of the Constitution
to impose its own policy views and to
supplant the proper role of the
legislative branch so I I think in terms
of judicial activism that is something
that all judges have to guard against
that is something that the Supreme Court
has to guard against and throughout our
history we've seen that some of the
worst moments in the Supreme Court
history of in moments of judicial
activism work where courts have imposed
their all own policy preferences thank
you thank you mr. chairman thank you
very much senator Graham back let me
make an assessment here as to the
potential second round
Senator Leahy do you care for a second
round they do Senator Schumer I infer
that all those absent do not I will ask
them well on this side I get it you and
could you find out really now right now
yeah senator hatch senator Cornyn
that's a qualified pass all right you
qualify pass for senator rats well we
will proceed with the second round
that's I think we will finish before
five o'clock as it appears to me mr.
Cavanaugh you declined to break twenty
minutes ago you may you may reconsider
that without petition at any time you
choose if you'd like a brain Thank You
mr. chairman I'm okay you're okay okay
then you've established a number of
qualities without further combat
Cavanaugh on the second round which we
begin now I've noticed a reticent on
your part to criticize people not
necessarily a bad habit you didn't want
to criticize Karl Rove II didn't want to
say how you vote in the impeachment to
criticize President Clinton you didn't
want to criticize judge prior on row
being an abomination you didn't want to
criticize judge bivvy on the bimmy memo
you didn't want to criticize mr. Manning
Miranda I didn't want to criticize Judge
Pickering anything want to criticize the
American Bar Association now I don't
consider that didn't want to criticize
Justice Scalia Justice Thomas I don't
consider that necessarily bad qualities
senators sometimes criticize people in
fact it's seldom when we don't that
seems to be a stock-in-trade by the
United States senators and perhaps most
people in public office maybe that's our
call that really in connection with our
oversight responsibilities but let's
take up the values behind your
declination to criticize
as to what judge Pickering is alleged to
have done never mind
the hypothetical would you ask lawyers
to write letters for you if you were a
judge sitting on their cases and you
were under consideration for a higher
court would you would do that no no mr.
chairman when you were asked about mr.
Manny Miranda the investigation is still
ongoing but there's been considerable
information about his having invaded the
Democrats computer system and downloaded
it and used it for partisan political
purposes now without characterizing it
as larceny would you engage in that kind
of a practice no mr. chairman would you
sanction and participate in in torture
no mr. chairman would you accept the
principle that you could inflict any
amount of pain in order to get
information as long as you were seeking
information no limit that's the amount
of pain you'd influent no mr. chairman
would you engage in rendition send a
suspect to a foreign country where
torture was a practice in order to get
information where you wouldn't have to
commit the torture on US soil and no mr.
Chairman I don't want to know mr.
Chairman I think that's only issue I
have not been involved in I don't know
the facts I know I know you haven't been
involved in but now we're trying to find
out your values and I you you you
haven't criticized certain people and
somebody may say you haven't answer the
question so let's go behind the
hypothetical or let's go behind the
criticism and let's take up the values
which is what I'm asking you now now you
didn't want to criticize Justice Scalia
or Justice Thomas but when you were
asked the question
would you consider yourself in their
mold you selected justice Byron white
and Justice Robert Jackson now mr.
Cavanaugh there may be some implicit
criticism there but I will move beyond
that why do you choose justice white
what are his quality is distinguished
from Justice Scalia or Justice Thomas
that you choose justice white I did not
want to comment on currently sitting
justice the reason I chose justice white
is for several reasons he was a rock of
integrity his work as Deputy Attorney
General and the Department of Justice
enforcing the civil rights laws in the
early 1960s I think was heroic
I think his approach to judging judicial
restraint in terms of recognizing the
primary policy that's enough why did you
choose justice Jackson I chose justice
Jackson no you're not permitted to
filibuster mr. Cavanaugh yes mr.
chairman why did chief Jackson
I chose justice Jackson because of again
his leading role in the Department of
Justice being involved in the public
enough mr. Cavanaugh now on independent
council you have some criticism of the
structure of Independent Counsel on the
operation you had with Judge Starr and
that's why you made some recommendations
for changes right that's correct and you
have a value not to exclude blacks
african-americans on peremptory
challenges that's your value yes mr.
chairman and I believe in proper
procedures to make sure that racial bias
does not occur in the courtroom and the
jury selection process okay my red light
went on on round two I'll yield now to
mr. Jerry he'd tell you as chairman I
and you know the reason I kept asking
about your taking seven months answer
the questions and I have found your
answer inadequate you you did spend
years vetting judicial nominees up here
and telling them what they were supposed
to do it everything out is difficult to
understand having told them how they're
supposed to answers you did not
understand
yourself be there's it made tomorrow the
White House is finally going to release
its logs of visitors to the White House
haven't been forced by a federal judge
to do so something they did not want to
do so I ask you this do you know mr.
Abramoff I do not you ever met him or
seen him at the White House no you ever
met Susan Roth Ralston who was Karl
Rove's personal assistant at the White
House formerly worked as mr. Abramoff
secretary she works in the deputy chief
of staff's office today I do know her
yes yes sir ever met David Safavieh no
when did you learn that he was being
investigated for receiving illegal
payments senator on that matter eyes I
think whatever I learned I learned
reading the newspapers so yeah prior to
the time that it became public he's
being charged you did not know about it
part of that time that's correct senator
have you ever met Michael Scanlon no
when did you learn that he was being
investigated for criminal activities
these are all people at the White House
that's why I'm asking I don't think
Michael Scanlon worked at the White
House I could be wrong about acted well
go ahead when did you first learn it if
his again reading the newspapers is all
I know about that matter and what about
the disclosure are the identity of
Valerie Plame I do not know anything
about the facts and circumstances of
that matter well you were equal so you
did not do anything about it or we're
not required to do anything about it you
did not do anything about it I I don't
didn't know anything about the facts and
circumstances that matter I know it's
under investigation of course and it's
not part of my responsibilities not nor
have I learned about it
so what you would know about it be what
you'd gotten from news sources public
sources what I've read in the newspapers
that's that's correct I don't I do not
know the facts
circumstances that matter it's under
investigation of course
did you see documents of the president
relating to the NSA's warrantless
wiretapping program no what about
documents related to the
administration's policies and practice
on torture did you see any documents on
that whatsoever pointing to the
president no the only time I've learned
- the legal memos and have read some of
them was after there was public
disclosure some of those memos in the
summer of 2004 and I think in late 2004
early 2005 I might have read some of
those memos of course they'd already
been publicly released at that point
what about the presidential signing
statements indicate a reservation on the
part of the president who's with
regarding provisions in law passed by
the Congress you have seen those signing
statements have you not signing
statements come through the staff
secretary's office and also when I was
in the counsel's office before that
counsel's office sometimes has a role in
signing statements so signing statements
traditionally for past presidents and
this president identified potential
constitutional issues such as
appointments clause presentment clause
or write these signing statements
reserving presidents rights of whether
to follow or not follow some parts of
the law of the signing they've been more
you said this has been done by past
presidents there's been more done by
this president - all past presidents put
together so let me ask you this there
was a great deal of publicity here in
the hill and at the White House when the
President signed the so-called McCain
Amendment against torture or inhuman
treatment of detainees and prisoners far
less fanfare a couple days later there
was a signing statement to basically
reserve the president reserving the
right determine who's going to have to
follow the law did you see that signing
statement I did see that signing
statement was your reaction to it
senator the president has made clear
that the United States and this
government does not torture or condone
that's not my question you believe that
the President had a right to reserved
the exercise of parts of that law that
he might not like or to reserve its
application to certain people my
understanding of that signing statement
which is what the president's spokesman
said a few days after was issued in
questions like the one you're raising
were raised to him is that the president
intends to follow that law as written he
shook hands with Senator McCain and the
Oval Office about that he's made clear
and the president's spokesman made clear
we're going to that the administration
will follow that law as written as I
understand it then why why the I mean
you saw the the signing statement it
passed through your hands why have a
signing statement then that basically
reserves the president's right not to
follow the law if it doesn't want to why
why do they don't do you have any qualms
about these kind of signing statements
senator that signing statement as I
recall it identified a number of issues
other than the one you're talking about
on the specific sentence that relates to
the question you're raising I believe
the signing statement identified that
this fell into something that the
president has authority on to go back to
justice Jackson's Youngstown concurrence
that I well that also makes it very
clear if there's a law that the
president's ability to act as justice
Jackson point out is that it's absolute
minimum do you let me ask you this does
the president if he's claiming a
commander-in-chief override or anything
else does he have the authority to
authorize an excuse to use the torture
interrogations of enemy prisoners
despite domestic and international laws
prohibiting the practice senator the
president under article 2 of the
Constitution has the constitutional
responsibility to follow the
Constitution and the laws passed by the
Congress of the United States that's
part of his responsibilities and
treaties we let him finish his answer
he's in the middle of an answer right
including including the laws against
torture reflected in 18 USC 23 14
related provisions including other
statutes
by this body that's part of his article
to responsibilities including treaties
that this country is entered into which
had become the law of the land once
we've entered into them when the treaty
is the law of the land the president has
the constitutional responsibility to
follow the Constitution of the United
States and the laws of the laws of the
United States
so is your answer and I don't want to
interrupt you from answering does the
president have the authority to
authorize or excuse the use of torture
interrogation of enemy prisoners when
there are domestic or international laws
that we've entered into prohibiting the
practice senator the president has said
that the administration follows the law
that the United States does not torture
then the United States does not condone
torture the United States does not
participate in torture the president
said that many times he said you met
with Senator McCain in the Oval Office
on one statute the president's spokesman
clarified a question you raised and said
that the president intends to follow
that law is written you know it's funny
of why I would think differently after a
Bouguereau even after the rendition by
Americans by Americans the authority of
the commander-in-chief renditioning of
people to countries knowing they'd be
tortured thank miss Cheerilee Thank You
Senator Leahy senator hatch anything
further just a few seconds and you know
I I don't know why we needed this second
hearing in fact I know we did yeah
everybody had a shot at the first
hearing and frankly I don't see any
reason and especially when I reach her
this transcript of the ABA hears and
they say this nominee and I'm just
reading a few of the accolades towards
you and by the way I read the ABA
description of each member on the
Standing Committee number of them are
Democrats there have very strongly
supported Democratic senators and others
but found you not only qualified but
welcomed
here's what they say this nominee enjoys
a solid reputation for integrity
intellectual capacity in writing and
analytical ability the concern has been
and remains focused on the breadth of
his professional experience and the most
recent supplemental evaluation has
enhanced that concern taken in
combination with the additional concern
over where this nominee is so insulated
these should be unable to judge fairly
in the future in placed alongside the
consistently praiseworthy statements
about the nominee in many other areas
the 2006 rating can be seen in context
and then he said when he was asked by
mr. Jensen and whether you know you've
provided a few negative quotes about mr.
camera on your written statement he said
let me underscore pate that we didn't
find him not qualified there's not a
breath of that and this reporter what's
the early report we found him qualified
minority well-qualified what I said at
the end is that in fact many people said
he has a solid reputation for integrity
intellectual capacity a lot of people
refer to him as brilliant and an
excellent writer writing and analytical
ability these are great skills to bring
to the Court of Appeal study sir
this is just a few of the comments we
just give a couple others mr. tobert
again for the Bar Association the
positive factors have been changed the
whole lot he is found to have high
integrity he is found to be brilliant he
is a very skilled writer and legal
analyst he has those components and I've
said this before but I think you were
probably doing better things he has
those skills that will serve him well
certainly on a federal court well I
asked him I said I said so I just wanted
to mention that I'm correct and looking
at the record that he's had some 24
people evaluated him and not one it's
not I'm not qualified mr. Tobler of the
Bar session I don't know the number to
be 24 I take your word on that but it is
true there's not a single not qualified
vote in the picture I wonder what all
the fuss is about frankly to force a
second here and now I acknowledge our
colleagues have a right to do that but
the fact of the matter is I haven't
heard anything here today because
anybody to vote against you
who is fair I just got to say you know I
came here
best thing to hear Samba bastok things
that that might show that you that they
think you might not be qualified to sit
on the court my gosh your experience is
virtually other than the law firm
experience where you were partnering
Kirkland and Alice one the greatest law
firms in the country the experience has
been an experience of service and
everybody with whom you've worked has
felt the same way I want to put in the
record mr. chairman a whole list of
letters from former attorneys general
former solicitors general your
classmates both bipartisan Democrats and
Republicans all of whom supports you
holy and without reservation again I I
just say you know I don't want to
question my colleagues they have a right
to ask these questions and I suspect
they had a right to call for this second
meeting but I haven't heard anything
here today that justifies having had the
second meeting and all I can say is that
I must I'm proud to support you because
I believe that the Bar Association is
right here
thanks mr. chair thank you senator hatch
Senator Schumer many of us had hoped
that maybe mr. Kavanagh would answer
some of the questions he didn't answer
in the first hearing in the writings but
he has not in general in your written
responses to Senator Durbin you said
well let me first you said you were not
involved in the nomination process
either of mr. Hains or of judge Bybee is
that right you said that in reference to
questions asked before I did not have
primary responsibility and ask that were
you involved there's a committee that
meets to discuss prospective judicial
nominees were you involved in those
discussions digital voice opinions about
Haynes and by be at that committee
center I don't remember the timing of
that but if it was when I was in the
counsel's office it would have come
through the judicial selection committee
when I was part of it and it would have
been part of the committee
can you give me a yes or no answer were
you involved in discussions involving
the nominations of Hanes or by B Sarah I
believe those were or when I was still
in the counsel's office so if the answer
be yes thank you I think before you I
want to I want to I just like I don't
have the record in front of me but I'd
like to look at what you said in
reference to other people's questions
there here's what you said in your
written questions in response you said
it's fair to say that all of the
attorneys in the White House counsel's
office who worked on judges usually ten
lawyers participated in discussions and
meanings concerning all of the
president's judicial nominees do you
remember we use supportive of the
nominations of Hanes and by be at the
time I don't remember talking about them
but they remembers the administration
who people had worked with and knew so I
don't remember he finishes answer I
assume it would have come up at a
judicial selection committee meeting
committee meeting and maybe I should
explain how that works senator I I don't
have that kind unless I can have a
little extra time and I'd be happy to
let him explain oh that's part of the
answer to the question Senator Schumer
okay then I'll okay you can't have an
extra two minutes go ahead well that's
very kind of you thanks mr. chairman go
ahead judge Gonzales when he was counsel
set up the judicial selection committee
which included members of the White
House counsel's office as well as
Justice Department officials within the
White House counsel's office one of the
associate counsel there were eight of us
would ordinarily be assigned to
particular States particular circuit
seats so then you then you say I
understand that I'm just an airman
please let him finish we have limited
time all right then I'll ask for a third
round because there's limited time here
and we know the general structure it's
described in the writings I am asking a
specific question I am asking whether he
can recur whether mr. Kavanaugh can
recall whether he was supportive in
those discussions he said here it's fair
to say all of the attorneys participated
in the discussions concerning all of the
president's judicial nominations he's
brilliant he went to every law school I
asked him could he remember
or the best law schools Haynes and bi.v
no he can't okay I'm now on that he said
so he probably did I'm asking if he
remembers being supportive of either of
those nominees not you were not in
charge of those nominees we've that
we've established that three times over
did you were you supportive in those
general discussions which you say all of
the attorneys participated in if both of
them were nominated before July 2003
than the quote then the answer is yes
were you supportive I didn't know he's
right in the middle of an answer Senator
Schumer let him finish that was not my
question then if the answer would have
been yes because it would have come
before the judicial selection committee
thank you now let me ask you this what
would you please what question were the
answer is yes that there would have been
discussed at the judicial selection
committee oh I thought you were asking
yeah you were answering so please answer
my question not the general procedure
were you supportive of the nominations
of Haines and Bybee when they came
before that committee and did you
dissent did you say nothing were you
supportive with respect to and this is a
line that I think judge Gonzales is
maintained with respect to individual
deliberations about prospective judicial
nominees that's something that it's not
appropriate for me to disclose in this
context and why is that because the
president benefits from having candid
and full discussions of his prospective
judicial nominees and for those to be
candid there has to be a guarantee of
confidentiality there let me ask you
this do you ever recall having dissented
when a name was brought before this
committee in the general discussions did
you ever into any of them do you ever
recall having dissented and saying I
don't think this person should be put
forward senator and all the
deliberations that we've had on judges
and other issues I've never been a
shrinking violet I've always been put
forward my views and you can assume I
put forward my views strongly once judge
Gonzales or the president makes a
decision I also understand I'm asking
you did you dissent about
potential nominees before the pret when
you the committee discussed it before
the president made a decision
you were the committee that was vetting
these people and I'm giving you an
answer that says there was a lot of
deliberations a lot of people would
debate the merits of nominations and you
can assume that various people would
disagree about protected you disagree
senator I don't know any of these
nominees what when any of these
potential nominees when it came before
the committee did you you said you're a
person of strong opinion which you are I
know that our my colleague the chairman
said you didn't criticize this list of
people but I have a long list of people
you did you work for you free to
criticize who happen to be at a
different political viewpoint but that's
not what I'm asking here I am asking you
did you object and say I don't think
this person or that person should be
nominated when you were in this
committee senator I do not think it's
appropriate from that I'm not asking a
specific person I do not think it's
appropriate for members of the
president's staff to disclose whether
they agreed or disagreed with
recommendations on particular judicial
nominees and why is it not appropriate
there's no privilege I presume because
that would chill the candid discussion
that the president benefits from in
hearing advice about pursuing - not to
mention a specific name but to simply
ask someone whether they dissented on
any would chill discussion that if you
admitted you dissented on some then
people would be chilled from saying that
I didn't ask a particular name I'm
saying that there were candid
deliberations in the judicial Selection
promote at that there would be
particularly
that would come up for consideration and
there would be debated to do dissent you
did you ever say in the meetings I don't
think this particular person belongs on
the bench that is not a question that
expect that should chill anybody that in
fact I would argue sir is your
obligation to answer us we don't have
much of a record he
my colleagues here justifiably have said
you've had a lot of government service
and that's what justifies we try to find
out anything about that government
service and we don't get an answer now
what is the harm to future deliberations
of future councils deputy councils by
your saying I did or I didn't dissent
and say certain people shouldn't be on
the bench other than you just don't want
to answer the question for us and we
can't compel you
particularly when everyone on the other
side is going to vote for you no matter
what you say Saren let me try it this
way on a previous question you had I
said I needed to check with the council
I went back Karl Rove is does
participate in the White House judicial
thank you Committee on this question I
would like also to go back to the
council if I could and I try to provide
you a timely answer in this moment but I
have some follow-up questions I would
then ask you to answer as well what was
the basis of your dissent I don't want
to ask about specific people I'd like to
I think it's relevant but there you
might have an argument I'd also like you
then if the council says that it's okay
to answer that you tell us the basis for
the dissent was a temperament was it
ideology was that this was it that
Senator Schumer your two minutes over
the extent of time that means your nine
minutes plus into this questioning how
much longer would you like I'd like
another few minutes I think it's
important I can't tell you it depends
where the questions go but I won't take
a I won't take a half hour I won't take
much time well we're gonna you're you're
you're almost up to ten minutes we're
going to go to this side for a minute or
two and we'll come back to you thank you
no that's just fine that's just fine
thank you mister I don't want you to be
cut short when you say that everybody on
this side is going to vote in favor of
mr. Cavanaugh if that raises any
suggestion that everybody on this side
is not going to vote against him that
might draw some raised eyebrows not wait
a minute that's my five medleys it's my
five minute start start the clock I'm
going around 3:00 because Senator
Schumer is going to have
around 3:00 I'll come back to you too
senator coburn I've listened to your
testimony very carefully mr. Cavanaugh
but frankly it's been hard because there
been so many interruptions but let me
plow this ground again to see if I
understand what what you've said you've
said that when you had a certain job up
till 2003 it was your responsibility to
sit on a panel a group of people
evaluating judges is that right that's
correct senator and then when you change
jobs there's no longer your
responsibility to sit on the panel
evaluating judges that's correct
and what date is that that be early July
2003 and that's when you change from
being an assistant White House Counsel
to being staff secretary that's correct
okay now you said that you're no
shrinking violent and you disagreed when
you thought that there was something
somebody up whom you disagreed with as
to their qualifications isn't that what
you said yes mr. chairman and you
wouldn't specify which individuals you
disagreed on you you you're not going to
specify which individuals you disagreed
on because you think that's part of the
deliberative process and it would
unfairly impinge upon freedom of
discussion there or a chilling effect is
that what you have testified to to
Senator Schumer
that's correct mr. chairman all right
now you also testified as I could dakar
belit through the interruptions that you
don't remember which people you
disagreed on or do you remember which
people you disagreed honestly not asking
you which ones they were but do you
recall the specific individuals whom you
thought should not be submitted for a
judgeship I think the question here is
because there can be multiple candidates
for a particular judgeship that would
come up and you may rank them
differently from how the ultimate
decision comes out that doesn't mean
that the final selection is a bad
decision are you saying then that you
never said as to any
I think they're unqualified but only
that you ranked them well mr. chairman I
don't think I don't think I should talk
about that issue would you at least
without checking well let's explore that
for just a minute we're talking about a
generalized procedures and you sit on a
panel this is why your assistant White
House Counsel and you are asked about a
variety and a number of possible
nominees for a judgeship that's that's
the procedure do you feel comfortable
answering that yes yes mr. chairman
that's the procedure and you have said
that you're not a shrinking violent and
you speak your mind so at some point you
either disagreed with the qualification
of an individual or thought that they
fell behind some others in terms of a
ranking system is that a fair inference
or conclusion from your testimony I
think it is mr. chairman the one thing I
want to be careful about it's talking
about the qualifications of an
individual as opposed to ranking
individuals and that's that's in terms
of the qualifications of an individual
some people are more qualified than
others you may rank them differently
from how some other members of the
committee and you may disagree with the
ultimate selection I'm sure that happens
all the time and well I'm sure it does
too that's that's what your testifying
about now without you how many
individuals were you considering many
many many weren't you there have been
hundreds sometimes that have been
confirmed and that means that there are
many hundreds more because you assume
for each one of those spots
okay so we're so we're in the hundreds
now I'm not asking you whom you
disagreed with or whom you ranked where
do you remember
among those hundreds you confirmed and
hundreds more you considered among those
hundreds and hundreds of people do you
recall the can you recall specific
individuals and rankings at this time
some three years after the fact I
certainly mr. chairman do not recall the
specific deliberations I do recall some
of course and and that's you know that's
natural there is it is also natural for
there to be debate and discussion on
judicial nominations by the judicial
selection committee that's what we want
so that the president gets the best
advice the best recommendation
recommendations of the staff okay there
are some that you recollect because they
stand out for one reason or an out of
the right and you're not correct that's
correct and you're not prepared to
identify those individuals because you
believe that would restrict the candid
discussion we've been through this on
Chief Justice Roberts on the Solicitor
General's Office we've been through it
on a lot of decision-making process and
I don't want to get into the question
about limited privilege here today I
just want to understand your thinking as
to why among those whom you remember you
will not identify and as I think you've
testified in response to Senator Schumer
but I'm not sure because of the garbled
nature with the interruptions that you
won't be specific even as to those whom
you remember because you don't want to
impinge upon that deliberative process
is that right that's correct mr.
chairman okay
Senator Schumer you got five more
minutes and then we're going to wrap up
your side I just want to respond to
something that you said mr. chairman
this idea of a closed mind I spent 17
months as chairman of this committee
start the clock if Senator Leahy is
speaking that I said I spent 17 months
as chairman of this
Mittie during President Bush's term we
moved 100 judges had to Republican
chairman since both friends of mine
neither one of them has moved President
Bush's nominees to as fast as I did so
let's not talk about closed minds or the
or the or the partisanship and we did
this notwithstanding the fact that the
Republicans had part and pocket
filibustered sixty four of President
Clinton's nominees and the few years
leading up to that we move we Democrats
moved 100 to President Bush's nominees
to in 17 months an all-time record what
I wanna know is how do you approach
recusal you've been a key member of the
bush cheney administration the we have a
president making sweeping claims nearly
unchecked executive power a number of
these matters issues are going to come
before the DC Circuit assuming we have a
check and balances the the Congress has
not done much in the way with some few
notable exceptions has not done much in
the way of checks and balances the rest
of America waits for the courts to do
that how do you determine what you're
going to recuse yourself from what about
if it's a challenge of the
administration's practice a rendition of
sending people other countries to be
tortured but if it's about the
administration's interrogation practices
and in detention what about their
wiretapping of Americans without warrant
so NSA where where do you recuse
yourself the senator if I am confirmed
the DC
circuit I will do the analysis under 28
USC 455 there's some specific recusal
obligations in Section 455 B which I
would of course follow there's also a
more general recusal prescription in
section 455 a which talks about when a
judge's impartiality reasonably be
reasonably might be questioned I would
do the analysis of that in by looking at
the precedents that other people have
gone from the executive branch to the
judicial branch of course I would do it
by consulting with my colleagues and
doing by looking at the facts and the
circumstances of each particular case I
think it's hard to make a rich Hughes
whole determination in the absurd you
think if a question came up about the
administration's practice of the Bush
administration's practice of rendition
of people other countries would that at
least raise a red flag in your mind
senator on recusal questions generally I
don't think it I can because I haven't
done the work necessary identify
specific cases and we don't know what
those cases might be where I might
recuse I can pledge you a serious
process I understand there could be
issues I would follow the precedents
look at the precedents consult with my
colleagues what if it's what if it's
questioning a policy of practice with
which you were involved at the White
House
either forming the policy of making the
decisions would that be a pretty easy
one well I think without knowing exactly
where you're saying on 21 28 USC 455 B
there's a specific prohibition that
applies to government lawyers who've
worked on certain matters and it's
depending on the hypothetical if that
fell within that I would have no
hesitation about recusing and just
generally senator I would have no
hesitation about recusing I just want to
do the work and know the facts and
circumstances before I make any
determination these are not dissimilar
two questions I asked Judge Roberts both
when he was up for DC Circuit and the
Supreme Court in this case I was
satisfied with his answer and I voted
for
in his case I understand those Chairman
senator Feingold is not able to return
for another round he's written a
follow-up letter to mr. Cavanaugh but I
asked that letter be made part of the
record without objection it can be made
part of the record but he's not seeking
follow-up answers from the witness is he
well I think that this is a yeah there
is one there is a specific one with
which the annulment nominee is
expressible in this respond and so
that's very specific in it well idle
capital has been handed as he hasn't
seen as yet as de staël
I want all the questions for mr.
Kavanagh to be asked today but because
as stated during our executive last week
it's the intention to vote on him on
Thursday and he's going to stay here
long enough to within reason to answer
the question so with this I would hope
that he would look at this and I hope
that he might be prepared and I think it
can be done fairly fairly quickly well
let me take a look at it first but give
him a copy and I'll pass it on to him
and meanwhile we'll go on to Senator
Coburn for a round of questions Thank
You mr. chairman mr. Cavanaugh coming
back to you as a president has an
obligation to try to preserve
presidential powers through signing
statements in that the purpose form
presidential signing statements have
been used a throughout our history
senator and in particularly in the last
four presidents that I'm aware of to
identify specific constitutional issues
that can arise and provisions of
statutes they're usually focused on
things like the appointments clause
suppose there's a new board or
Commission and the appointments there's
an appointments clause issue the
recommendations Clause when reports are
required that might be inconsistent with
the recommendations Clause this is part
of the conversation the dialogue that
the executive and the legislative branch
have on issues like this through the
years and so but it's an important
function of the President to elicit
those areas of potential
conflict on a constitutional basis and
to put a statement from the sitting
president in in regards to those is that
not correct that is correct center and
presidents have been doing that for
throughout our history so so a
reasonable man could believe somebody
would not necessarily believe in torture
but might put something into the record
on a signing statement that might be
related to preserve presidential powers
or appointments or some other area and
not necessarily believin in torture but
be castigated that they do believe in
torture because they happen to put that
in not for the purpose of torture but
for the purpose of protecting and
enhancing or not enhancing protecting
and securing what was there before in
terms of presidential powers is that not
a reasonable man couldn't think that
saram presidential signing statements I
think the counsel's office in particular
the Department of Justice you seek to
rely on the precedents of the executive
branch and legislative branch
interaction where there been issues
identified and when new legislation
comes up say an appointments clause
issue a presentment Clause issue or
recommendations clauses you to identify
that kind of can that kind of issue and
that's been done throughout our history
and I think it's very traditional would
you think much of a president who's they
just ignored not doing that they just
decided well that's not important I'm
not gonna do that
senator I think all the presidents at
least in modern times have have
identified issues when they come up and
again it's part of the conversation part
of the healthy back-and-forth between
the executive and legislative when these
kinds of issues but it is also done to
preserve a point of view so that when
it's looked at it in the future somebody
can understand what the debate was at
that time
exactly exactly senator puts it on the
record people know it's an open process
then there can be discussion about
issues that might be for example an
appointments clause problem with a new
board or Commission then there can be
discussion back and forth if there is a
problem it can be fixed in a subsequent
statute for example and do you believe
President Bush's statements on torture
President Bush has said the United
States does not torture and I know what
he said I'm asking you do you believe
absolutely
we senator and so you don't have any
heartburn over his signing statements in
in regard to anything if they're
consistent with what he said and what he
believes that's absolutely correct
center he has stated that the United
States will not torture and does not
condone torture follows the laws against
torture he's made that clear alright
thank you I yield back mr. chairman
mmm Thank You senator Coburn Senator
Schumer you had a little over ten
minutes on an opening statement six and
a half minutes on your first rant a
little over ten minutes on the last
round I want to conclude by five o'clock
you have five more minutes
it's Chairman's the lifetime appointment
and I think we should be allowed to ask
questions you put people in a box if he
goes on I get and I don't get a chance
to answer all my questions if I try to
get to my answer by cutting him short
you take some umbrage I don't think
that's a fair way to proceed okay well I
don't cut you short I asked you not to
cut him short well then just give me the
time that I need instead of telling me
we must end at five o'clock for a
lifetime appointment well your questions
may exceed the tenure of his appointment
Senator Schumer no my questions are fair
questions for somebody who's gonna have
tremendous power let's put let's put the
clock back in five minutes and start in
and see how we do thank you mr. Chairman
I appreciate it and I just make a couple
of quick comments here first I did not
ask you mr. Cavanaugh
although senator Specter interpreted
that way to name specific judges I asked
you did you ever dissent not on and I
was explicit not on not on specific
judges and you said to me you would not
be able to answer that question until
you checked with Council is that correct
that's correct sir
now did you then answer senator Specter
saying you did dissent did you change
that answer that's what I'm trying to
figure out here I think it goes senator
to whether there was a different rank
order in particular discussions or
whether you thought someone was on
qualified for that I didn't I never
asked about a rank order I asked you
specific senator Specter did but he was
saying what I asked you and he was not
interpreting what I asked you I asked
you explicitly was there ever a nominee
you don't have to name him and I was
explicit that you thought should not go
forward and you said that not will you
ranked him but that you said should not
go for and you ranked him now you said
to me as I recall we can check the
transcript that you weren't sure you
could answer that question although I
expressed befuddlement as to why because
we weren't asking a specific name are
you willing to say that you block
certain not you that not blocked that
you urge that certain nominee certain
potential nominees not go forward or do
you want to go to counsel and see if you
can answer that question senator and I'm
sure I in the course of two and a half
years of debate over judges I just I'm
sure that all of us had preferences that
weren't reflected in the final decision
is that your question my question is did
you do you recall having ever stated
that you don't think X potential nominee
should move forward for whatever reason
I'm confident senator that on occasion I
would have rank ordered them differently
from how that so that the final decision
was different from what my
recommendation would have been I didn't
ask that I asked you did you ever
express at these meetings of the ten
council this person should not be
nominated do you want to go back and
check your recollection and answer in
writing before tomorrow can I just ask a
follow-up please just do you mean should
not go forward period regardless of who
else was in the mix is that the I mean
yes that a person regardless of who's in
the mix there might be certain people
who didn't think deserve to be in the on
the bench whether someone else was in
the mix or not I think that that kind of
question goes to the heart of the
deliberative process that the president
relies on for picking judges to talk
about whether you disagreed with the
final selection really that's something
the president okay
I'm not asking an explicit name I am
just asking you whether that happened
and you can't recall you can't give me a
yes or no answer to that
senator again I think that would go to
the heart of the deliberative process as
I understand it it's important to
protect the deliberative process so the
president gets the best advice when the
president makes a decision to nominate
someone m'p RAAS s four members of his
staff so I was going to go out and say
well I disagreed with the President on
that or I even if you don't name names
to say I disagreed with some of his
selection I think that's inconsistent
was there you know
let him finish and well you're gonna I
have 127 left here you're gonna let me
ask a few more questions if I might how
many I don't know a few it wouldn't
finish the answer mr. Cavanaugh if you
can remember where you work I think
that's inconsistent with the
deliberative process that the president
needs to rely on to pick the best judges
for the federal judiciary okay I fail to
see any reason I think people are put on
the committee to make that very decision
and I have a lot of questions that put
questions in my mind why you refuse to
answer that question but let's move on
you did say you would check with counsel
earlier and then you came back to me and
about Karl Rove and you said he was
involved in the process okay in what
capacity was he involved how often did
he consult with you and the other
councils about prospective nominees
against Aaron he's part of the committee
the the committee meets weekly I'm not
sure health and he attended I know he he
participated though was it more than
once he was a regular participant in the
committee of 10 well it's it's actually
much bigger than 10 that's the giant the
committee was a regular participant in
the decisions in the committee process
there's many more than 10 I'd say it's
about and what do you recall he's right
in the middle of an answer Senator
Schumer go ahead just wanted to be
careful to make sure you understood that
the committee at least when I was on it
I don't I haven't gone since 2003 but
included that all the people in the
White House counsel's office plus
several Justice Department lawyers plus
people from other White House offices
liked the legislative office on occasion
I think would
10 so it's many more than 10 I don't
know the exact number man did he ever
discuss politics as relevant to why this
judge should go forward or that one
shouldn't like it's an important state
to us it's an important reason so and so
wants him did that ever come up Sara I
think it's important not to just blows
the internal deliberations that might
occur of course we work very closely
with the senators in each state we've
worked closely in New York with you and
Senator Clinton on judicial nominations
and judge Rajee judge in many District
Court nominations we've worked we've
worked well together with you and so
that's that's of course part of the
process is okay that the the Senators in
this home state are suggesting so and so
is that person the best person and then
a back-and-forth with the home state
sentence that's part of the process in
those discussions would often occur at
the those kinds of discussions would
often occur and so I think that's and
Karl Rove was involved in those Karl
Rove participated in the process mm-hmm
okay let me ask you this what who else
was on that you said Karl Rove was a
regular participant who else who was not
in the counsel's office was a regular
participant senator I would think the
counsel's office if the counsel thought
this was appropriate could provide you a
list if she thought it was appropriate
and I don't know the answer to that
question you said you consulted her and
it was okay to mention that Karl Rove
was part of the process mr. Kavon I'll
answer the questions within the scope of
your recollection not we're forever
referencing anybody else who can provide
a list I don't want to have any Springs
outstanding you're here today to answer
questions thank you answer the questions
as to what you know mr. chair mr.
chairman senator schumer aight i don't
know that it's appropriate for me to
list everyone who's on the committee i
can tell you the offices that are in it
the White House counsel's office the
Department of Justice offices that work
closely with the committee office of
legal policy on judges karl rove was
involved chief of staff's office on
occasion
I think those are the the people if I'm
leaving anyone out Senator Schumer I'll
make sure it was there ever anyone
outside of government who participated
in these groups no okay and if you told
us that karl rove participated is there
any legal imaginable legal reason that
you couldn't tell us who else
participated by name not by their
offices let Sara Schumer I think I was
saying that I could tell you the offices
I don't know that could remember all the
names sitting here of who's that's
particular meetings but I told you the
offices and I could anyone from outside
those three offices you mentioned the
White House Counsel the office of legal
counsel to Justice Department anyone
else from outs Rove was not part of
those anyone else from outside of those
offices office of legal policy again
going back
it was office of legal policy at justice
just right clear thank you I'm going
back to my own time from 2001 to 2003
and keeping in mind what the Chairman
told me to testify what I remember
the Chairman's trying to move your
nomination at forward as quickly as
possible that's why he did that Senator
Schumer and I finally found an agreeable
point I think I just wanted more than
you think but if I'm leaving everyone's
out I'll send it in later but
legislative affairs of course on
occasion because we deal with the Senate
staffs the chief of staff's office on
occasion when you send in later I
Scrabble on anything you're gonna send
in later has got to be end by tomorrow
it'll be in this evening okay I'm sure I
just want to make sure I'm not leaving
anyone else so the the offices that I've
mentioned deputy chief of staff's office
on occasion I would participate mm-hmm
okay
[Music]
just one final line of questioning mr.
chairman and this involves what you said
last time
which is that you testify that what the
president is looking for in nominees is
is sorry is nominees who have respect
for the law and who understand the legal
system and the role as a judge is
different from one's personal views do
you believe that Justice Ginsburg and
Justice Breyer have a
Beck for the law I absolutely said okay
why then do you believe the president
keeps talking about judges in the mold
of Scalia and Thomas
if the methodology the the rationale is
respect for the law senator I think the
president's talked about a general
judicial philosophy that he's looking
for in perspective judicial nominees but
you indicated to me in the first hearing
that you didn't think ideology played a
role at all in the selection of nominees
which I found incredulous senator the in
the first hearing there was I don't
think I explained clearly what ideology
could entail to my mind the president
considers of course one's judicial
approach whether someone believes in
interpreting the law and not imposing
their own policy views we do not ask
your views on specific cases or issues
do not ask your views on policy issues
that might be that might exist the
president looks and wants his staff to
look for people who share the kind of
judicial approach he's outlined and of
course with this president as with past
presidents most judicial nominees are of
the same parties so let me ask you this
if you believe that Justice Ginsburg and
Justice Breyer have a respect for the
law as well as Justice Scalia and
Justice Thomas why are there so few
nominees who seem to have the judicial
philosophy of Justice Ginsburg and
Justice Breyer and many many many who
have the judicial philosophy of Justice
Scalia and Thomas
if ideology doesn't play a role in this
election I'm not saying it's wrong that
it does and I'm not saying that it but I
was surprised that you at your initial
hearing said it didn't if respect for
the law is to the judicial philosophy
that's what the president is looking for
then theoretically the panoply of
nominees should be much broader in terms
of all kinds of things their political
affiliation their judicial philosophy
their views on a variety of
shoes and you're saying it didn't play
any role when you were there or others
were there and I find that hard to
believe given who the president has sent
before us and one other point I'd make
just parenthetically the reason I
mentioned I sort of had an idea that
that side of the committee would vote
one way but was because they voted YES
on every single nominee the president
has sent forward thus far there hasn't
been one single descent of the 240
nominees we're on our side
there have been a lot of yeses and a lot
of nose so it would be hard or at least
by past experience to judge that that's
why I said that but anyway go ahead
senator I want to be very clear that the
president has said that one's judicial
philosophy does play a role does in fact
play a role in the types of judges he's
looking for your approach to judging
whether you're someone who believes in
interpreting the law and not legislating
from the bench he's made very clear well
that does matter what doesn't matter is
your view on and what we do not ask
I understand you've said that and I
accept that you don't ask about specific
issues like are you pro-choice or
pro-life but still do you think that for
instance Justice Breyer and Justice
Ginsburg have any less respect for the
law or are less likely to try to
interpret the law than say Justice
Thomas or Justice Scalia
well senator is a nominee for an
inferior court I don't think I should be
talking about the Supreme Court justices
and trying to assess them what I will
say is the president that's now about
between what he will say is letting
finish his answer he didn't answer my
question that's why and you may have a
follow-up question thank you what I will
say is the president has made very clear
that he does believe in inter pointing
judges who will interpret the law as
written
who will not legislate from the bench
who will not seek to impose their own
policy views he's made that very clear
so judicial philosophy is a part the
judicial selection process he said that
many times and I just want to be do you
think
that justice Marsh former justice the
late Justice Thurgood Marshall and say
Robert Bork have a different view of
what interpreting the law is as opposed
to imposing their own views or do you
think they each do it the same way I
think judge Fork has made clear that he
has a different interpretive approach
than say justice Marshall for example in
his both in his testimony before this
committee and in books he's written
since Judge Bork made clear he had a
different type of approach than justice
even though both have a respect for the
law and understand the legal system Sara
I think your words yeah respect for the
law is a necessary qualification of
course but it does not encompass
judicial philosophy that's a separate
issue to look at in terms of them and
the reason I ask you this is we rarely
get an opportunity to question somebody
who has sat on the committee in this
administration who does this but it's
obvious to me then what you say that
clearly judicial philosophy and ideology
make a difference here and you've more
or less said that there's nothing wrong
with it
Democratic presidents might do it too
but that is clearly happening would you
disagree with that judicial philosophy
is part of what the president looks at
because he's made clear he wants to
employ judges who interpret the law so
how is that different than the word
ideology which I use to you with the
first hearing because I think ideology
can encompass four different things and
we need to be very clear what we're
talking about so there's no confusion
ideology could accomplish political
affiliation it could encompass your
general approach to judging it could
encompass your specific view on
particular cases and it could encompass
your policy views the first two are the
factors that are looked at but if what
you mean by ideology is differing
judicial philosophies then clearly the
president if you mean that then clearly
ideology enters into the selection
process right judicial philosophy
matters and if that's how you're
defining it then that judicial
philosophy thank you mr. chairman
thank you a Senator Schumer mr. Kavanagh
I don't want the record being complete
in any way senator Feingold rather
Senator Leahy handed to me a letter that
Senator Feingold reportedly wrote to you
dated yesterday marked hand delivery
relating to answers to questions three
through seven which he had asked you
before did you get this letter aside
from what was just handed to you mr.
Cavanaugh look at me
did you get this letter did you get it I
was told about this letter and that now
never mind what you were told about just
answer my question did you get this
letter I don't I don't believe I got
this letter senator I'm just making sure
okay well it's dated yesterday senator
Feingold was here he could have had to
did a letter or he could have asked you
these questions but he says he didn't
ask you questions 337 so I'm gonna take
take his part and ask his questions
although he should have I don't want any
loose threads hanging out of this
hearing I'll ask them as best I can
because his questions are not with all
due respect self-explanatory mr. chair
death has marked up the record on his
written questions saying that he had
asked you all of the parts of question
three that's correct
and moving on to the question four he
asks you about judge Dee Brooks myths
not resigning from a club which he
promised during the Senate hearing he
would resign from if you promise to
resign from a club
mr. Kavanagh will you keep that promise
and resigned from the club yes mr.
chairman on to question five this also
refers to judge Smith but the relevant
questioner is your values and you
probably already covered this in
connection with other questions but I'll
ask it to be sure that everything judge
find Google once is asked is asked would
you conform to the judicial
disqualification statute 28 USC Section
455 and recuse yourself if it is called
for by that statute yes mr. chairman on
the number six there was a question
about whether judge Smith complied with
advisory opinion number 67 which sets
forth the standards for free trips to
educational seminars sponsored by as he
put at ideological organizations such as
the Montana based foundation etc will
you comply with the requisite rulings
with respect to acceptance of free trips
yes mr. Chairman I certainly will would
you go further and declined to go on
free trips they're quite of us around
here who declined to go on free trips
because of the complex questions
involved and the reporting I made a
speech at NYU several years ago on a
legal issue and took the train up and
back and read about it in the newspaper
forever
would you consider declining going on
free trips that's my intention mr.
chairman for the reason you identify
that I would not go on any trips and you
know basically would go by pay my own
way philosophy that's - and Senator
Feingold last question number seven was
related to a district judge after
confirmed by the Senate to a district
judge ship in Texas
he told the New York Times that despite
his confirmation right now he's running
for state representative if if if you're
confirmed will you run for any other
office in the NRA is it with that
articulator value that you would avoid I
will not run for any other office mr.
chairman why is it wise answer now back
to a revisit on dissenting and ranking
we played a tennis game here with
Senator Schumer questioning you and my
trying to clarify it and Senator Schumer
going back and asking some more
questions if some might say not
clarifying but but Senator Schumer would
not agree with that so I won't press it
but let me review the bidding here very
very briefly you engaged in a system
where you ranked perspective nominees
where there were a number of people for
a single judgeship correct that's
correct mr. chairman through a process
it may not be as formal as you're
describing but yes basically all right
in in in that in that process were you
ever called upon to dissent in Senator
Schumer's terms that is to say candidate
X is unqualified as far as I'm concerned
or did you pursue the ranking which
you've already testified to well you
certainly wouldn't with respect to
candidates of course there would be
certain candidates you'd say I don't
think this person's suitable for the
bench when you're talking about
candidates I think Senator Schumer was
talking about whether ultimate nominees
if there was dissent on Oldtown nominees
took I was taught if I might mr.
chairman oh he'll do senator shank you I
was asking about pretension I was asking
about potential nominees were there
potential nominees that you said as it
came before this committee
the ranking system I've said it three
times I think it's clear as a bell even
if my colleague doesn't want to save who
came before the committee who came who
would disgust at this committee who you
said I'm not asking names who said this
person does not belong on the bench and
I don't think we should recommend to the
president that that person be nominated
it's a very simple clear question that
I've asked three or four times so I mean
can I go and at one point you said to me
that you'd have to ask counsel if you
could answer that question and at
another point I believed you said that
you didn't think it was appropriate to
answer that question and now in
reference to Senator specters question
now maybe you didn't know it was
potential nominees you said well why
don't you answer it if you if you
understand that question go ahead if
we're talking think everybody
understands the general I don't care
about everybody I care about him do you
understand that question I now do I
think there might have been some
confusion of course when there's a list
of candidates that come to before the
committee you might say someone's not
qualified of course before the judicial
selection committee that's some people
just are not suitable for the bench they
might be recommended by someone for
example they they get on a list of
recommended people that come from from
that you know from the senator from a
governor from a member of Congress and
you might assess that person's record
say you know what that person is just
not suitable for the federal bench I
that of course that happens okay then
may I ask a follow-up question mr.
chairman yes what were the real give
give us some of the reasons did you ever
invoke the notion that their judicial
philosophy wasn't appropriate for a
judge the president's made clear that
judicial philosophy matters so if
someone did not share the judicial
philosophy that the president has
articulated of course that would be a
reason yeah also and you would say that
you would say I don't think mr. X or
miss X
shares the president's judicial
philosophy what well I think the
president's made clear that he will not
appoint judges who seek to use the bench
to impose their own I understand so you
would say that on occasion when a
nominee came before the committee well
that's what the president wanted so we
we work for can you give him a simple
yes yes thank you thank you mr. Chairman
I think the question was pretty clear
and could you do you recall and again I
don't need the name of the nominee an
example of why this person wasn't
appropriate in terms of judicial
philosophy if if someone in our judgment
or the assessment of the committee or
the assessment of the interviewers
concluded that this person in either
direction had policy views that they
couldn't separate from their judicial
reviews who didn't seem to understand
the difference that I think I've
articulated today between the judicial
role and the legislative role and there
are such people who sometimes get
interviewed that someone doesn't
understand that role then that person
would be could be deemed and not
suitable and how often did that happen
and I don't need an exact number or
anything like it I think most of the
candidates that members the Senate
recommend that governor's recommend
usually come with a proper appreciation
the judicial role but there are
occasions where people share different
philosophy or where people simply do not
someone might be interviewed who simply
does not seem to recognize the
distinction which is critical in my
judgment between the policymaking role
and the judicial role that but you would
never use the words too liberal too
conservative or would you well I think
to activists would you you'd say to
activists if someone doesn't understand
the judicial role and you would say that
person believes in judicial activism and
not judicial restraint and the
president's made clear to us and made
clear the American people that he's
looking for people who are believed in
judicial restraint to be judges and of
course
that person wouldn't fit well the
president told us so you would
occasionally say somebody would be too
activist in your opinion to meet the
president's criteria well that's what
you're saying that mr. Cavanaugh can you
give him another yes I'll give him a yes
and say that's what that's what the
president has said and just and people
twice women and it's just one more
question were there ever people who were
to activists from the conservative side
as opposed to the liberal side yes your
last question mr. Cavanaugh you say yes
yes attaboy CY the senator from
Pennsylvania was a very fine prosecutor
he's very good at helping his witness
[Laughter]
all out in the open all transparent
Senator Graham you've been waiting
patiently I've tabulated senator
schumer's questions were 42 at 3/4
minutes so you are limited now to 37 and
3/4 minutes I really don't have much dad
but that won't stop me I found it
actually fascinating uh I mean I'd you
seem no worse for the wear
senator Kennedy staff has a good
question I think I don't mean to maybe I
shouldn't have said that but I think
it's good enough question I'll make it
my own
mr. Bobby judge Bobby if you had known
well you repudiated the memo you thought
it was not good legal reasonings that
correct
the Bobby memo you thought yes the
administration has repealed that memo
and I stated my own personal agreement
with repealing the memo
would that have disqualified him in your
opinion from being a judge if you had
known it senator I I've drawn a line
here today which i think is important
for maintaining the integrity of the
judicial selection process not to talk
about people who are currently sitting
judges or other judicial nominees by
name I don't think that's appropriate
for me and I'll just end it right and
take my time there's a fine line between
doing your job as a White House
counselor being part of the judicial
selection team and being a judge
yourself there's a line between being
advocate and being the
judge I think you understand that line
and I think the questions have been very
very good to be honest with you and I
expect President Bush to live up to his
campaign promise of picking strict
constructionist non judicial activists
as he sees it that's what the election
was about and if you've been part of
that weeding out process to make sure
somebody in the conservative movement or
the liberal movement doesn't get on the
court then I think not only have you
done a good job in the White House
you're fulfilled your obligation to the
president now your obligation is no
longer to President Bush your obligation
is to those people it came to come
before you like they came before you
mother
you're gonna have a lot of characters
come before you in a courtroom with
their cases on a pill and some of them
you won't like and some of them you may
feel close to philosophically if you
could just in a very short statement
tell me what your job what you will do
with that responsibility no matter who
the person is that comes before you what
is your job now Sarah if I were
confirmed I believe in the absolute
sanctity of ensuring the integrity the
sanctity and integrity of the judicial
process which means treating all parties
who come before the court equate I think
I did that as a law clerk for the two
Court of Appeals judges and Justice
Kennedy I understand that function
that's really central the whole judicial
role equal justice under law doesn't
matter where you come from it doesn't
matter what you look like it doesn't
matter what your background is when you
come into that courtroom you have the
right to present your case and if you're
right on the law you should prevail on
your case doesn't matter and that's
that's the genius of our system it's
been part of our system throughout our
history and if I were confirmed I pledge
to you and to all the members of the
Senate that I would absolutely fall
within that tradition I look forward to
voting for you thank you thank you very
much mr. Kavanagh as previously
announced we will proceed to a vote on
mr. Kavanagh on Thursday
I believe at this state and I've checked
with staff who have been listening
attentively as have I there are no
outstanding questions for you to answer
going over what senator Feingold letter
said and I believe you have responded on
the karl rove answer and i believe all
the issues have been responded to i want
to compliment you on your stamina I will
reserve comments on your testimony until
we meet on Thursday when we will discuss
your